ladies and gentlemen councillors
officers welcome all to the planning
development control
committee b meeting this morning first
of all remind you of some domestic
arrangements
please ensure that you maintain social
distancing from all of the persons in
the chamber
and in the social areas during breakouts
please ensure that you wear a mask
unless you are speaking
or if you're unable to do so that you
used the hand sanitizer and white
provided
please maintain such distance at all
times during the meeting and during any
breaks
and please ensure that microphones are
muted when you're not speaking
that you do not interrupt the other
speaker members are reminded that they
should not have alternative
communication lines open
i.e team chats and that's if you are
contacted by a third party
during an application you should bring
this to the legal advisor's attention
that's if you are attending the meeting
to speak and persistently interrupt the
meeting
you may be asked to leave additionally
you'll be invited to speak and ask
questions by the chair of the meeting
and we'll be using the e-voting for this
meeting on modern.gov
and council casting i realize that
you're going to be doing this verbally
by hand
i'd like to remind everyone present this
meeting will be broadcast live to the
internet and would be capable of
repeated viewing
the whole of the meeting will be
recorded except where there are
confidential or exempt items
if you make a representation to the
meeting you'll be deemed by the council
to have consented to being recorded
by entering this meeting as a speaker
you're also consenting to being recorded
by the council and to the possible use
of those sound recordings
for webcasting or training purposes the
council members of the public and the
press
may record film photograph or broadcast
this meeting when the public and the
press are not lawfully excluded
a few introductions uh i think it's on
my left everything's behind me today
i've got ian depressed he's our legal
advisor
thank you german's not here so uh john
payment g who is the area planning
manager
uh robert carmichael governance officer
daniel cameron
alex scott and catherine hale all at
back who are our
case officers today and we've got board
members
joining us councillor matthew hicks
council john field who is going to
represent if he can get here
if not we've got a letter from him and
counselor andrew mellon who also forms
part of today's committee
so let's move to the agenda please
apologies for absence and substitutions
thank you chair this morning we have
apologies from councillor kathy guthrie
and substitution from councillor lavina
hattingham for council guthrie
thank you chair thank you and noted um
to receive declarations pecuniary and
non-binary interest by members if there
are any
there are no declarations of lobbying
there are none and declarations of
personal site visits
okay councilman uh we have visited the
site in back to north so i won't be
voting on that anyway
thank you anybody else good
we'll now move to the confirmation of
the minutes of the meeting held on
the 28th of april 2021 are there any
points arising to the accuracy of the
minutes
in that case can i have a proposal
please
cancel casting and a secondary counselor
melon thank you
governance officer will now conduct
electronic votes
thank you chair if members can please go
to the modern.gov app and go to the plus
sign in the top right hand corner
and go on the subsection of voting slash
attendance and click on the vote that is
currently in progress
i will now take counselor carsten's vote
thank you that's four please and
i believe council stringer are you able
to vote on
mondo is it not working
i'm sorry i didn't say that on youtube
so is that sort of just comfortable
thank you
so chair all results have been in that
is seven votes four and one abstention
thank you that's carried and uh i will
sign those at the end of this meeting to
receive notification of petitions in
accordance with the council's petition
scheme
received chair thank you and now we're
going to look at the
schedule of applications but before we
begin the determinations this morning
i'd like to draw everyone's attention to
the fact that the application dc
twenty one zero one seven four seven
and two one zero one eight zero zero at
the sight of jay brahany
contractors at florida road creating st
mary have been withdrawn by the
applicant
and the search will not be heard today
the ward members in parish council have
been informed ahead of this meeting
so i'm going to move on to the first
application which dc
21 stroke zero zero seven five five land
to the south of shop street
wallingworld wallingworth in suffolk and
i invite the case officer daniel cameron
to introduce the application to the
committee daniel
thank you chair morning members um yes
we have
application dc 21 000 755
land to the south of shot street in
worlingworth and this is reserved
matters application
for appearance layout scale access and
landscaping for the erection of 26
dwellings just by way of background
to the application the outline was
approved under dc1704689
and that approved details of layout
subsequently um
we received a non-material amendment to
the outline
that removed consideration of layout
from the outline now given that that
application
would be returning to members for
consideration of the out of the layout
as part of the reserve matters
it wasn't felt by officers there was any
detriment to the consideration of the
application so that's why you have a
revised outline if any of you remember
seeing this site previously
so here we have the aerial plan of
whirlingworth with the site shown
edged orange and shaded purple
we have the
neighbouring john deere site here we
have a
agricultural site just to the north and
then the residential is
to the west and the south following the
run of the road here
if we just quickly looked at the
constraints map you'll see there's a few
buildings shaded orange there's a grade
two listed buildings
and we're also adjacent to the built up
area boundary of whirling worth
as it currently is in the adopted
development plan
and if we move on to the joint local
plan
you'll see that the settlement boundary
for williamworth is now shown in purple
and rings the site and the site is now
allocated within the joint
local plan for the delivery of 26
dwellings
and those numbers are counted within the
five-year housing alliance supply
trajectory as well members
there's a few issues to be aware of with
this site as we as we go through and
hopefully they're clear
for you from the report um as submitted
um the first issue that i think we
probably want to have a look at is
um the timing and just to sort of
mention to members the reason why we
have this application coming with
late papers and the recommendation that
we do um
normally an outline application will be
submitted with a timing condition that
requires submission of reserve matters
within three years of the
date of grant and then a further two
years to commence following the
agreement of the reserve
matters in this instance this hasn't
been applied and there's three years to
commence the development
the outline application was approved in
2018
and there is now a need to commence on
site or the outline will lapse
um so that's why we have the application
brought to you in the manner it is
members
um i just want to turn your attention as
well as i flick through some of the
plans that were
provided for you those outside now
just to a few of the other issues that
have come up as part of the
application i think the first one to
note and this is also some information
for you in late papers members
we've got an additional response from
the flood and water team
um the county council they now have
removed their holding objections such as
their content for the application to go
forward
i think on the basis of that it would be
prudent to alter the recommendation
because we don't no longer
we no longer need their approval for the
details
and also i think probably it'd be worth
removing the the requirement for any
conditions
um at the end of the report members of
the flood and water team deemed
necessary
because they've indicated to us in the
in the late papers that those aren't
required
um while we quickly talk about the
flooding issue it's worth picking up the
comments from the parish council
um they note an existing issue with the
anglian water file network that
occasionally leads to flooding around
the community centre
um we contacted anglian water on this
and the parish's
notes indicate that angry and water are
looking to remedy this situation
um the response from anglian water
hasn't said that we're looking at
something that would
exacerbate that issue and then not
content to object to the development
coming forward
um so i'll quickly run through some of
the plans since we've got them so we
have the
the site layout so from the outline we
secured a large area of open space along
the frontage and this is retained
and then we have 26 individual units
provided within the site
all are now provided as detached or
semi-detached dwellings all of them as
houses so we have no flats within the
scheme any more members
and that has benefits in that we've been
able to provide a private garden to
every
unit and moreover we have on-plot
parking provided for every unit as well
whereas previous the previous layout
included some use of parking course
we have comments from the highway
authority with regards to the
application
the application has been revised in
light of those comments
um annoyingly the highways authority
chose to respond to the discharge of
conditions application rather than this
one
but i can report there's no objection to
the improved details so there's there's
no issue there for
them um
come forward that's the wrong one and we
have the massing plan
so you can see there's a number of
single-story buildings shown in sort of
a light green teal color these are
garages there are 19 carriages provided
on-site to some of the dwellings
and then we have three bungalows
provided within site
one here on the plot three
one here and then one here and you'll
see that those correspond to the areas
where
we've had public representations from
the properties to the southeast about
potential amenity issues and to the
northeast about potential amenity issues
so the inclusion of those bungalows
effectively means that we don't have any
issues with
um potential overlooking and
overshadowing is also reduced due to the
scale of the
buildings
if we come onto the materials plant
we've got a quick um run through we've
got mainly red brick and
clay pantowel buildings proposed
although there is some um
black weatherboard slate and uh black
panther with um
gold brick so quite reflective of what
we have in the local palette materials
and we'll show that when we come on to
the
images of the site as well members
we've had an update to the fencing plan
in light with um comments from um
neighbouring properties and as well
the um play services landscaping team
and i'll come on to a few more of the
place landscaping comments when we look
at the landscaping plans for your
members as well
what we have got now is a low hedge
running along the
frontage of the site
we have areas of
close boarded friend fencing and hedging
to either side
and then at the back we've got a timber
rail
and hedge that will run along the back
and then at the back of these properties
we'll have a post and rail fence that'll
mark their
rear boundaries so in terms of
maintenance of that hedge
that's not left up to any one property
owner that would be retained by the
developer
and the imposition of that fence just
means that that hedge is then
easily maintainable from both sides
and if we come to the landscaping plan
as well members we've actually got two
options before you here today so one of
the comments from
place landscaping was they were
concerned that the number of trees shown
on the landscaping plan would mean that
the other
grasses and wildflowers within the
public open space would fail to thrive
um the applicant's looking to maintain
this area themselves so there's no issue
of that
cost if there's additional tree planting
coming back to the council but what the
applicants have asked
is just to consider these two options we
have option a
reduced tree planting in line with the
landscape services
comments and then also option b which
shows a denser area of
tree planting but that would likely have
biodiversity and ecological
benefits as well as landscape
improvements
you know so we can really double down on
replacement planting within the site
if we come now to the photos just to
show the site so this is the view along
shop street
there's an area of trees and hedging
visible along that frontage now that is
to be removed
none of the trees are protected by tpo
and we're not in a
special landscape designation or
conservation area that would require
their attention
we do have significant replacement
planting within the scheme even if we
decided to go for the lesser planting
option put forward by the developer
now in terms of that that's necessary
because what we have been delivered as
part of the scheme
is a footpath to connect into the rest
of the village along this frontage here
but what we also have is we've got a
pumping station as part of the drainage
strategy to come in
and angling water will require parking
and visibility space from that parking
that will
necessitate the removal of that
vegetation unfortunately
this is the view the other way so we can
see the site here
and then the business site here
and then this is where we sort of come
over the side it's fairly flat
um there isn't very much of note within
it we have the bank of trees
away to the back while outside of the
site boundary
and then as well you can see some of the
neighboring residential development down
the lane to the side of the site
if we pull back slightly you can see
some of the development that we have
um facing on to the site we've got sort
of quite
traditional um form red brick slate
vendor slaves and red brick slate and
then obviously
in the previous and you can just catch a
glimpse of them there we have
pantel and black motherboarding as well
and obviously crossing the site we have
a public right of way
and we have comments from the public
right-of-way team um
objecting to the public right-of-way
crop being crossed by the estate road
now it's interesting to note that when
we consulted the public rights of way
team
outline they had no concerns and the
public right of way was to be crossed by
an estate road at that point
no diversion of the public right of way
is required by this application so the
public right-of-way
other than likely being stopped up
temporarily during construction
would remain unimpeded once the
development was in place
the previous layout that was um agreed
by members
outline did require the the deviation of
the of the public right of ways would
have had
an additional legal process to have gone
through
um i wanted to pick up as well about the
the point made in the report for you
members
about in terms of sustainability i'm
just going to quickly
flick through the the house types and if
members have any particular questions on
them we can
come back to them at that point um
but in terms of the sustainability
aspects of the site we've got air source
heat pumps provided to every dwelling
so we've got about 37 38
of the energy needs of the buildings
being met through
the inclusion of the air source heat
pumps and we're also looking at
[Music]
dwellings that are built in excess of
the requirements for building
regulations for sustainability as well
part l
so that we're looking about a 10 to 11
increase
over what is required
in building regulations and we're also
looking at
meeting minimum water efficiency
requirements for all dwellings as well
obviously all the units have on-site
parking as well
and 19 of them have garages so in terms
of electric vehicle charging points
everyone has the potential to provide
them within the site
as and when they choose to to take on an
electric vehicle
and there we go i'll pop back to the
site plans and i'll turn over to members
and take questions on the reports
thank you daniel members do you have any
questions at all
for the case officer counselor
thank you um is that um tuck goals next
door
and what exactly is the the buffer
situation there i can just see a sort of
shaded area but what exactly is that
thank you so this is
existing access down the side
so tuck wells has um i don't think
there's anything on that side but down
this side we have a close boarded fence
so that was required at
outline stage that was a requirement of
our environmental health team
just to say we need something to try and
stop noise during working hours
so that's retained but we also have some
hedge planting as well down there
so we have the the the noise benefits
of the close board defense but we've
also got some
slightly um more aesthetically appealing
boundary planting given the area members
will know in the
comments from the heritage team um they
were particularly concerned about the
close boarded fencing down this side of
the site
however i think given the concerns of
the environmental health team
i think i'm content as officer to
balance that and say there's probably an
interest to having the noise from
from the adjacent site reduced
yes i just have two questions one is for
the legal officer
uh on page 15 it mentions
pre-application advice
and it says the application form notes
advice being delivered by officers
is understood to be given outside of the
formal pre-application process
i.e it wasn't paid for therefore any
advice provided is not
binding that presupposes it is paid for
it is binding
that is not the case that paragraph by
being written is actually potentially
bringing this council into disrepute
uh and i don't think the paragraph
should be there at all no advice is
binding on this council
in that case uh we'll go to the person
that know uh mr prairie police
sorry um um well i'm very happy to give
what advice i can does
perhaps the officer might want to
explain that further if you can
mr cameron sorry members no i felt that
something needed to be in there just to
make
you aware that there had been
pre-application advice i completely take
the point about the
interpretation of the the paragraph as
it's written
um yeah no i mean
officer advice is officer advice and and
i think there is a
an expectation that where
pre-application advice is given and paid
for that the council will be able to
[Music]
deliver a decision in line with its with
its advice unless material
considerations
um prove otherwise
but obviously regardless you know
pre-application advice is advice given
by officers it shouldn't be seen as
being binding on
the decision of members who of course
are the decision taker in this
um instance i just didn't feel it was
correct to not
indicate to members that there had been
some pre-application
um discussion um even though it was
outside of the the paid framework
if i may um now thank you for that mr
cameron i
yeah i mean i think all members
understand pre-application advices
is two things it's to use a lawyer's
phrase but
totally without prejudice i.e it is as
mr cameron says the
um advice of an officer and on the
understanding that if the decision is
made by members as it as this is it's
not that advice is a recommendation it's
not in any way binding on them
secondly in any case all pre-application
advice is subject to consultation isn't
it
and to change circumstances and not in
that sense the officer may
change their view at some point i think
in this case mr cameron wished to make
the explanation to you that it was
not it was of a less formal kind and
perhaps the wording
has had a rather an unhappy result as
cancer strings noted but i think i
understand it was made with
good intentions actually one further
question if i may cheer
i'll just let uh mr clementi come in and
i'll come back to you if that's okay
thank you
just in respect of the pre-application
advice if i can just
withdraw that last sentence of that
paragraph
i think that would resolve the issue so
we formally withdraw that
on this document can i also just ask two
other things please if i may
um just to clarify to members formally
that the recommendation before you
has altered as a consequence of uh just
make sure
members are clear on what's before them
has altered because of the difference in
what's come back from the
suffolk county's flood team so the
element within your recommendation in
your
papers that talks about further
agreement necessary from the floods team
is essentially removed the
recommendation before you is to grant
planning permission subject to
conditions and just
one last point dan might need to help me
out on this
um because i'm fortunate i'm catching up
slightly because i was
thinking another officer was going to be
here so just to clarify the point
uh the landscape plan you had on the on
the screen
which landscape plan is before members
to consider
a or b because i wasn't clear um both
so a would more closely reflect comments
back from play services landscaping and
their concern about
the number of trees provided in that
area of public open space
however the developer still feels that
there's a benefit in terms of
biodiversity and ecology and as well as
landscape in providing
a degree of replacement planting
in terms of
maintenance the the developer will be
taking on the maintenance of the scheme
anyway so there isn't a cost
associated with maintaining the scheme
to the council it's
purely the advice from landscape
says we probably want a few less trees
so
okay so essentially we've got we are
asking members to decide which
landscaping plan they like
right one has less trees one has more
trees
thank you council stringer
yeah one other question uh you mentioned
that the
dwellings are going to be using air or
sea pumps and they'll have electric
charging points etc
out of the 40 plus structures on this
site
how many of the roofs will actually face
south
so in terms of
facing south we don't have any um
roof slopes directly facing south
everything's presented
gable end on but you would have
capacity within
most dwellings to uh incorporate some
element of
solar panels or photovoltaics within the
scheme how
we'll probably come back to that okay uh
councillor ghoul please and then council
hicks
thank you uh chair in a sense uh mr
peyton g got there before me
uh i was going to just make a suggestion
in relation to the
pre-app advice paragraph although
members
on this side of the chamber on this
occasion would really like to
always have the option of altering me
officer reports sadly
that's not a possibility uh i was going
to uh suggest a
some note in the minutes uh to clarify
the point
but withdrawal the paragraph itself is
simpler but there is
i think something to reflect on here in
terms of writing future reports
thank you thank you we will come back to
that uh council hicks please
thank you very much mr truman can i just
ask three quick questions um how many
visitor parking spaces are there for the
26 houses
um is there a current planning
application from tuckwell's to extend a
workshop next door of significant size
um and could you explain what the
pumping station is for that's on the map
in the middle of the area give more
detail on what its function is
thank you so we have visitor parking
spaces
um here we have two here two
two um within the report it's noted that
we've got
an excess of on-site parking provided
one bed units provided with two parking
spaces
everything else is provided with spaces
that
meet adopted standards and there's a
point to be made about garaging as well
i'll come to later but i think let's get
back onto the questions
i'm not aware of any applications from
topwell's expanding
um but i would take advice from the the
local ward member on that point
um and then the third point the pumping
station
here this is required by anglian water
and this is required to feed into the
networks and the existing networks
so be subject to further agreement
you'll see in the conditions we've
recommended
that we have control over the appearance
of materials for the pumping station and
for the substation that's also required
by the
um national grid
um such we control that aspect of the
appearance of the site but unfortunately
that is that's the requirement of
angular and water for
bringing forward the development and be
subject to the
you know the all the various approvals
and legal agreements that exist
sort of adjacent to planning after the
grant
could you just explain what the pumping
station is actually going to do
so it's a pumping station to do what
so um the pumping station will be
pumping
water into the falsehood network um
so that will be both from um surface
water drainage and then also foul
drainage
we we do have the agent and um we can
probably ask very shortly
uh we'll wait until you come on actually
nichola thank you
are there any other questions
um thank you chad um a couple of
questions
can you show us down on on the plan
where the right of way is
and the other question is the
existing trees are going to be removed
where where do they fit in with
the plan
apologies remember this one catch up
right so the public right of way just
runs
across the site here um if we go to the
next lot of photos so you'll see um
it continues to cross the the public
open space and then
down the side here and then we continue
over the over the farmland
if we quickly run to
the views across the site
it's very much just a natural product
right of way um
it just runs across the site
north south there um the existing batch
of trees on the site are these ones here
at the
now in terms of the design of the
pumping station that'll sit
just behind it angling water require
access for their vehicles to the pumping
station from the road
and they also require visibility
displays for those vehicles to
make safe access onto the highway and
exit from
so that's why we have the removal of
those
obviously from the landscaping plans
we do have a good amount of replacement
planting
and obviously it's then it members
discretion as to whether that is a
lesser amount within the public open
space to try and bring forward
other benefits in terms of the comments
put forward by the
landscaping service or to really sort of
push the amount of replacement planting
within the site
any other questions cash checks
yes can i just point out a planning
application was validated on friday the
4th of june
in the site next door for work for
increased workshop
crane etc
thank you that's of interest but
obviously we're dealing with this
planning permission so
let's stay on track with that but thank
you for that information
another questions okay um
kelsey stringer thank you for raising
the point i think it's valid and really
important actually um
and also thank you for the advice that
we received
it's right to be transparent is right to
be truthful and i think that's what
you're trying to do
however it's also right that we write it
the right way so we don't perceive it in
the wrong way
so therefore counselor gould and uh mr
payment g agreeing what you say and i'd
like that minuted has been removed as a
comment
thank you
okay we uh we have no representatives
from the parish
objectives or supports we do have the
agent which is uh
nicole perryman nicole you have three
minutes
let me know when you're ready to start
please
there we go good morning memphis um
thank you for your time this morning my
name is nicole perryman planner at
ingleton word
on behalf of my client flagship group
i'd like to begin by thanking council
members and officers for the opportunity
to speak this morning
the presentation by your officer and the
accompanying committee reported
comprehensive
and as such i don't wish to raise repeat
the issues covered
however i will raise a highlight a
couple of key points
as you've heard this application relates
to the reserve matters of layout
scale appearance and landscaping
pursuant to the outline permission
granted in 2018 by
some members of this committee the
principle of development and most of the
technical details are therefore already
approved
and consideration of this application
before you today relates only to these
specific
reserve matters the layout of the scheme
follows the same principles as those
presented in outline and has only been
improved by allowing the existing public
right-of-way to be accommodated
as well as incorporate incorporating an
improved mix of dwellings which most
notably
replaces flats with houses the
development retains a mixture of houses
in bungalows located in key areas to
avoid overlooking and preserve
residential immunity
whilst modern in appearance the
dwellings have been designed to a high
standard
with materials that reflect the local
vernacular this unique and enhanced
design style will be a flagship site for
the applicant in suffolk
with sustainability at the forefront an
improved fabric efficiency will ensure
that the requirements of building
regulations part l are exceeded and with
the added benefit of air source heat
pumps installed to all homes
the applicant is also committed to
providing a significant amount of
public open space with an extensive
landscaping scheme to improve the
environment for new and existing
residents of the village
across the site biodiversity
enhancements are also proposed
including new native hedgerows in excess
of 360 meters
bird nesting boxes hedgehog gaps native
trees and wildflower meadow
we acknowledge that the parish council
have raised concerns regarding drainage
issues in the village
this is largely an offsite matter and
granting permission to dare for these
reserve matters proposals will not
preclude the applicant
having to satisfy the necessary legal
requirements with anglian water under
separate legislation
and through the necessary existing
outline planning conditions
for both surface water and foul drainage
as such
members should be comforted that
adequate plane control is already in
place by condition to secure appropriate
drainage requirements for the site
in summary the proposed development is
consistent with the outline permission
and complies with national planning
policy and the adopted development plan
the proposals provide substantial
planning gain in delivering high quality
sustainable accommodation
of a high quality design that reflects
modern needs of living
to contribute towards the council's
housing supply as well as significant
biodiversity gains
there are therefore no planning reasons
as to why permission should not be
granted today
we therefore respectfully request that
members endorse the recommendation of
their officer
and grant permission today subject to
the conditions and requirements that
have been outlined
thank you thank you are there any
questions for the agent please
you go off lightly thank you
i'd now like to move to the ward member
please which is councillor hicks
thanks very much um so i've lived about
two miles from this site for the last 18
years
and the village and the community
expects the housing to come forward i
don't think that's an issue at all
the biggest issue which hasn't been
addressed and we keep circling
is that further down the village by the
community center
every winter the drains come up raw
sewage appears in the village
and every year angling waters say you
can keep building more houses
everything's fine now we're creating a
pumping station
to pump the sewage and the surface water
into the drain
system that is already creaking that
already overflows with raw sewage into
the village
and everyone is again saying it will be
fine
it simply is not fine for the residents
who every winter have sewage in their
garden
and the problem with this application is
my view is
it meets all the criteria it's very
difficult to find any reasons to refuse
it
but the fact is for the residents they
are going to suffer more
and this matter is not being addressed
and we've heard that the pumping station
is designed
to pump the sewage and the water the
water
into the system that further down the
system cannot cope
now i'm told anglian water will never
say there is a problem because if there
is then they have liability issues
so this just gets a worse and worse
problem every year
and i do feel that being rushed through
committee because in two weeks the
deadline is up
well we've had three years to sort this
out why do we have to rush it just for
the convenience of the developer
it should have come earlier and they
should have brought this sooner and the
matter should have been resolved
the floods team sorted the problem out
at 10 o'clock at night two days ago
because of the rush so it's very hard to
refuse
but i would really ask that we think
give serious thought to the residents
who have to have raw sewage in their
garden
and this is only going to make it worse
not better the principle of development
is there
the housing i'm happy with i think it's
a great scheme i would rather go for the
scheme
suggested by the place design team
rather than
what the applicant is suggesting but
the pregas problem is something that i
don't know how we control but it needs
to be addressed
thank you thank you uh questions for the
board member please
council hellingman thank you um
i see there's only actually two
objection letters matthew what do you um
you're saying the village is very
concerned there's only two so one what
do you say about that
well i think the biggest problem is the
aids applications from a long time ago
in terms of it first came up and at that
time there was debate and it was felt
that you know
the village like every village has to
say some development the problem is
it there's a pinch point in the system
that all comes just by the community
center and those poor residents suffer
every year and it's
the matter is getting worse with more
housing added to the system
so the parish council has met it's an
ongoing problem with every application
that comes in every application that
comes in the parish council has to say
the same thing the sewage system can't
cope
anglian waters say they can what they
end up doing is sending in tankers
instead of once a day
they send them in a few times a day when
it's really bad water to empty the
system
you know to try and help but it is a big
problem and this isn't unique to
whirlingworth i know we've heard it in
this committee before
council girl please thanks very much
this is not so much a question to
councillor hicks but
rather prompted by what he said and i
appreciate some
advice as casa hicks has just said this
is not a
unique uh unique unique example
in in this case while um the principle
of development may be one thing
um i'd like to ask the officers
of the scope that there is to refuse
this application
given given the concern about flooding
yeah mr potentially thank you um if i
can highlight to members the outline
planning permission page 82
you have already imposed a planning
condition on
the foul water drainage to be agreed
i don't understand that to be dealt with
yet that can be dealt with at any time
by the applicant and ultimately that
remains outstanding so there is still
scope there
for control and involvement of the
council in terms of this matter
that has already been posed under the
outline
are there any other questions
okay in that case we're going to open
debate
which should be good so who wants to
start
council casting
thank you very much yes some like the
design of this
i like the ground source heat pumps i
think it's
sorry air source um heat pumps um
[Music]
i do understand that they um take quite
a bit of electricity to run
i'm still not absolutely sure if there's
going to be solar panels um
fitted to the roofs or there's not going
to be any solar panels
so yeah so the air source heat pumps are
absolutely fantastic but they do use a
lot of electricity and i
quite like to see solar panels to power
that
but this this sewerage
issue yes we do seem to find this quite
a lot in them
mid suffolk villages we um people
connect their
storm drains to the foul drains and um
the um the systems can't take it they're
built a long time ago but um with the
conditions in place
i'd like to sort of um put that to the
the counselors in debate does that
protect
these um conditions for the sewage does
that um
protect that sewage or not because it's
some i'm finding it a little bit
vague there um i'd like to see a
condition
that this can't go ahead unless the
sewage problem sorted out but i'm not
sure
if these conditions actually say
that mr pogba gee
well there's two elements here first of
all we've already imposed a condition
on four water to be agreed and
essentially what we're dealing with
there in terms of the detail is that it
needs to mitigate
the burden of this development and we
need to be satisfied
of that the second point is to impose a
further condition or any other condition
in terms of foul water
drainage onto this reserve matters
application
we would have a bit of a disconnect
between what we're dealing with before
us which is appearance of
the buildings and and the layout to what
is
more of a technical issue of detail that
should have been resolved really at the
outline principle stage of whether the
development is capable to be there in
the first place i
i think i'll leave that alone for the
minute and i'll come back to if i have
to but
as far as we are concerned we already
have the control in place
uh so to add further control we're not
quite sure what we're adding control to
what more control can we add carson
mellon please
followed by cancer stringer brilliant
thank you chad um
just to sort of pick up on that um
condition from the outline
um just so we can be clear um
how how is that condition going to be
discharged is it only on the say so of
anglian water that they've sorted it or
is there something wider that will give
us some sort of uh
reassurance that the problem is going to
be not exacerbated by this development
this is going to be fun isn't it um
ultimately we consult two main
well possibly three uh when we get one
of these type of conditions in we do
consult angry water
we ask for their expert advice they are
the experts
uh we're not experts in the field we're
planning officers
we ask for their expert advice uh we
would ask our environmental health
health colleagues as well to pick up any
amenity issues of that particular
uh point and on occasion we will also
ask our building control
colleagues as well because obviously
drainage is part of their remit
uh ultimately under villeneux so um
armed with that advice we will consider
all those views to make that decision
ultimately
yeah thank you chad just to uh
re-rehearse the old chestnut about
anglia water
angry water is a privatised utility part
of it becoming privatised meant it had
to deliver
infrastructure no matter how much of it
came forward because it has the ability
to levy fees on those connecting
which it does with alarming regularity
so you cut it's not a planning
consideration
flooding in general is and they can
object if a design is going to
be somehow overwhelming to a current
system but they cannot
in law say we can't cope because in law
they've said they're already going to
so it does make that difference so if we
want to be able to check that
change that we need to change the
incorporation of how it's privatized
two things for me the planning for
climate change in the mppf is quite
clear
under paragraph 150 new development
should be planned in ways that
reduce greenhouse emissions such as
through its location
orientation and design the design here i
don't have a huge problem with a
slight issue with one part of the design
which i'll get to in a minute
but the orientation in in this instance
is particularly poor
there are 40 plus roof scapes here only
six of them face south so technically
you've got a heavy load coming in in
terms of electricity which is a good
thing
air source heat pumps electric charging
points all very good
but by this design you are committing
them to be able to not
generate electricity in the future and
that's just poor design
uh and that's in the mppf paragraph 150.
this this keeps coming up again and
again and developers need to realize
that having a balcony and a countryside
view
should be seen as secondary to orientate
the building in a correct way
that it can sustainably contribute to a
sustainable society in the future one
other small point is i take it the
balconies on these are glass
so we'll just get some confirmation of
that um nicole
are they glass yes
thank you right it would be helpful if
you are going to approve this that they
have a conditional clarification on them
so that the birds that are going to be
in living in the trees you're about to
plant don't just catter into them and
kill themselves
so that that would be really helpful
thank you chick
hello it's fair point and i'm sure that
you've taken it on board thank you mr
pope dude you have a comment
okay any other points of debate
yeah council war boys uh
well it's just really emphasizing i
think the fact
the concerns about the discharge of the
sewage
and whether or not an angle of water
seem to be caught in a situation where
they have to
accept that they can cope with extra
sewage
without actually any proof that they
will be able to cope
with the extra sewage which i think is
is the issue
which is this sort of um
rests doesn't it but whether it
can prove without
doubt that it can cope with the extra
search particularly it's going to
the mitigation appears to be pumping
pumping the surge into the existing
system
um the other matter is i mean
it's from the heritage team in
particular about the fencing on the
western
boundary which does create a very urban
landscape i accept that the environment
team have suggested this as a means of
um mitigating the noise from the
existing workshops
and here again we have a little bit of a
conflict where you've got
uh workshops existed in
uh beyond the building line in more or
less open countryside
alongside um
heritage assets are now being
incorporated into an urban situation
where they have housing next to them
i mean my argument will be perhaps less
noise should be
emitted rather than measures to sort of
uh control the amount of noise the
impact on the the residents who will be
there in future
i think there is some conflict there and
i think possibly
i'd like to see some other form of
fencing i've
i've seen this happen in rural
situations
it it does have a terrible visual impact
admittedly it is next to a workshop
um those are my points at the moment i'm
not convinced that we we
we should be actually just accepting
this layout
and these proposals so because i think
there are some
questions there in terms of particularly
in terms of its deliverability
anybody else want to debate
yeah counselor having thank you don't be
shy guys
um i think this is a tricky one because
um
as andrew says you know unfortunately
the orientation is not
with the sun although i do like the
designs of the i think you know i like a
lot of glass i think you know if you can
get heat from the sun that's got to be a
good thing
and it and it's it's refreshing frankly
to see a different design
being used in the usual um boxes um
but like everyone else i'm concerned
with the flooding that's happened in my
parishes you know i don't like the fact
that anglia water seemed to think that
everything's okay when
it is not okay but um there has only
been two objections from the locals i
don't know if they're the people that
are directly um affected by the flooding
um and if they're saying that it's okay
i think we're gonna really have to um
scratch our heads to come up with a
reason why we can't um go for this so
i think it is tricky but um yeah
anybody else
i'll make a couple of points and the
first thing is we've not had an answer
to councillor hicks point about the
pumping stations
nicole if you'd like to give us the
answer that'd be really good thank you
thank you chair um yeah just referring
back to the the flood risk assessment
that's
submitted with with the application um
the engineers have suggested that due to
the levels um
across the site falling away slightly
from shop street uh foul water will need
to be pumped to the existing public
sewage system and that's why the pumping
station is proposed
and that is through discussions with
angling water
thank you and hopefully that satisfies
your question yeah
thank you so i've listened to the debate
so far and at my own points of this that
yeah i think it'd be hard to refuse this
uh given what we've
been given in the papers uh and i accept
the points from the from the award
counsellor in the fact that
he's experienced it and he's seen it and
served the residents
but i also get your point that's there's
only two objections
although it was quite some time ago so
there's all this conflict going on
i do get the point from councillor
stringer about these solar panels it is
disappointing but i also understand your
point
in the fact that people do like to look
over the um open countryside
and they like south facing gardens and
in
right or wrong um it's it's about the
buyer that you know you've got to make
it attractive to sell the property
but i do get the environmental point
absolutely and i think it's a bit of a
shame actually
that you've not looked at solar paneling
because you're right
the heat source pumping uses a lot of
electricity so
the compromise would surely be some form
of solar system
to substitute that electricity
and provide it um yeah
the glass i get we are talking about
reserve matters i think that comes under
appearance
and i think that your point council
stringer is valid so i'd like that
within the conditions um because i think
it is important
and why shouldn't we do that as part of
the appearance
i do like the site though and i do like
the open area and i do like the amount
of trees that have been planted
um coming back to cancer warboys point
about the western side
i noticed in the conditions that there
is a point
about the additional boundary details on
the southeastern edge
it'd be really nice to have something
there about the western edge as well
and it talks about should members
consider it necessary well i do think
it's necessary personally
so i'd like an extra condition in there
for the western boundary
as much as the southeastern boundary so
more detail
and more effort in making that right
especially
with the workshop i'm glad you brought
it up because that is a factor
okay that's my point um so back to
debate
anybody council heading
well perhaps to provoke things but
anyway so i'm gonna propose that we um
go along with the officer's
recommendation and approve
this thank you we do have a um a
proposal
secondary council casting
yes thank you mr chairman i'd like to
second that thank you have a proposal in
the second day councillor stringer
yeah i would like to speak against the
proposal which i may we we have
sorry i'll take this off please do we
we really have to take a stand against
poor design
the mppf clearly tells us to do it and
here we go again
another development where views across
countryside
are put ahead of sustainably
being able to live in these houses in
the future and
preclude forever putting solar panels on
that's why orientation
is so important in the mppf it's the
single
biggest thing you can do to make a
development
more sustainable in the future if the
built form is to a high standard which i
believe these ones will be
anyway but if they're orientated in the
in the right way
that makes a significant difference to
their footprint
if each of these houses has one electric
car
and a air source heat pump that will be
almost
a mega watt of electricity that's one of
the turbines
at our airfield will purely be needed
for this site
because it cannot wash its own face in
the future
i frankly i love the modern design i
love all of that but i frankly cannot
sit here
and commit this extra drain on our
future
without making a stand thank you chip no
valid points
mr putin chief please i'll just clarify
the uh proposal that's been sec
first and seconded so are we talking
about the there's a grant
planning permission as per the papers
but obviously without further agreement
of the flood team
um and are you looking at those two
additional conditions one
was for glazing to be designed for bird
impact avoidance
and notwithstanding details west
boundary
details to be further agreed by officers
there was something else i was going to
say oh yes and which landscaping scheme
a or b coach having approved your
proposal
i'm going to say i like the one with
more trees
oh yeah and i've seen enough i'd like
one of the more trees you know
that's custom happy with option b yes i
think the council has made a good choice
with that one
for me there was only one choice from
the start
thank you and can you also both confirm
you're happy with both
additional conditions yes
yes mr chairman thank you i do get
council stringer's point just in summary
on this one
it is a shame um but i also understand
modern solar panels in fact you don't
always have to be pointing south
because actually it's not direct
sunlight it's light on most of the
modern stuff so effectively
you could do something to fix this
yeah and i'll give you a time to just
come back on it
construction uh condition attached to
the outline permission already
um some details have already been
submitted in support of that condition
so there is quite a detailed energy
report on there which is
where the figures um that mr cameron
quoted
regarding the airsoft heat pumps um come
from um and they do demonstrate quite
significant
exceedance of partel building
regulations
and they do confirm that that solar pvs
are viable on this site
but obviously they're not proposed
currently but
you're quite right chad that it is
valuable and it is possible despite the
roof orientation
so on that mr penguin g is there a
possibility of condition that would
further investigate use of solar panels
or a solar
solar energy system for those houses
this is the point i hate being a
planning officer um
no the the the trouble here is
we're dealing with not the principle of
something being put onto this site we're
dealing with the what it looks like
and layout and i can't add essentially a
plant
to every house because that wasn't part
of what this proposal is
um i appreciate i'm just trying
in terms of the outline planning just
one moment sorry
um in terms of it's important thank you
just take your time
anything in here right
so under your outline planning consent
you
have got already um
condition 4 page 78 prior to
commencement development agreement
measures to improve sustainability of
development
i'm not sure dan has that come forward
for agreement
i thought that might have done
separately
can i just check i'll check
um
[Music]
no i just need to check if an
application has been made that's
condition six that's not it
we do have an application for condition
six on the outline it's dc
21 025 is part of
a suite of conditions for uh
surface water drainage and far water
drainage as well yes but but we don't
have anything on condition four
as yet which is sustainability
dc2102532
so that's already been agreed no those
conditions haven't been discharged
though
they're with us still yeah they're with
us still okay
uh so we we
i don't think we can put anything on the
specific reserve matters but we
we do have a condition that we are still
considering in terms of the
sustainability aspects of the site
uh as a separate planning matter
we can only say that officers will bear
in mind your conversations today in
considering of that application
if that's all we can do it's all we can
do but i want to strongly listen to what
we said today and i want that minute
please
thank you chairman i'll just say i agree
i think mr
paytman g is quite correct legally thank
you that's where we need to be
stringer can i just make a small point
this is
you're in this bind because i don't want
to be rude it's because the design
is poor it hasn't even
because it's used a traditional style
garage even
they could have done an innovative
design on the garage that had a single
pen
roof on it that could have faced south
so that could have
uh added to the solar uh possibilities
of the future of these dwellings
along with perhaps battery storage in
the garage that's probably where the the
electric hookups going to be for the
for the cars this has not been thought
through
according to paragraph 150 it becomes
poor
in terms of in terms of that orientation
and the overall design it's it's that
that's the point i'm making and i'm not
trying to be rude because a lot of the
design is very very good
it's just that first principle of
orientation has not been well thought
through
thank you no you're not being rude
you're absolutely right in what you're
saying
but um but as i said you don't have to
point yourself anymore counselor custom
yeah i'd just like to um and speak to
councillor stringers um
um talking on this some solar panel
issue and i do
completely understand what he's saying
solar panels don't necessarily
go that well with air source heat pumps
because the time that you need
the um heat is usually in the winter
when the sun's very low in the sky so
only a south facing
roof will um do but that sun's gone down
by five o'clock
this time of year you'll be generating
until nine ten o'clock at night but
you don't need the heating um so
renewable wise we're relying on the wind
farms
outside and i don't want to go too far
away from the point all
what i wanted to say was i think
councillor stringer makes a really good
point
on this and i would say that's a bad
design
that these the roofs can't pick up the
um solar
heat quite quite as well with um these
air source heat pumps
but for me it's not something that i
would turn this down on
so um i just he makes a good point but i
couldn't
refuse it on this on those grounds
thank you councilwood boys
but as well as before we sort of plunge
down the route of having more trees
uh i just want to draw members
attentions to
place services comments on page 22.
and they quite rightly look forward to
the future when these trees grow
and their words are the large the larger
form
trees of the proposed trees could in
time create a dense canopy
effectively blocking out light to the
grass areas
and paths which would result in a loss
of immunity and the space's open
character these are trees
in this in a effectively a sort of park
within a
within a small estate and not an
appropriate place for something which
is more like a a small wood or coppice
it's it's a parkland situation where
distinct trees would be aesthetically
better but also
it would preserve the grassland and the
flowering grasses and
which are also effective stores of
carbon
so i think we do need to seriously
consider place services
recommendations here
thank you council willboys anybody else
casa norris
uh yeah i'm very undecided on this one i
have to confess
i do understand councillor stringer's
point entirely
and i have considerable reservations
regarding
the sewerage flooding issue
i can understand why i extend my
sympathies to the residents it's very
unpleasant
um but at the same time
with the reassurances that the planning
officer
has a chief planning manager has given
regarding any um
any measures that can be taken regarding
the sewage as far as is possible i'm
finding it very difficult to find
sufficient reasons to actually
refuse this application but
i will listen to the rest of the debate
thank you
thank you anybody else please
casa heading oh i'm just um i'm just i'm
thinking on what um councillor warboys
have said about the trees and just
wondering if we rather
you know um possibly made a too quick
assumption of you know more trees is
always a good thing and i have to say
that i do like wood the
woodland you know i'm as a
as an amenity and so i'm just um
i'm having a think is um does anyone
else want to speak about the two
landscape you know for against whether
we go for the more trees and there
possibly more for woodland
look or the sort of more opened
meadowland look
james what do you think kelsey custom
i'm still for the plan b
um i don't think i can understand
what place services are saying i don't
think it's
that much of an issue i don't um i i
don't think there's enough there to turn
it into a woodland i think the sun moves
gradually during the day and the
um you know the grass will get whatever
it needs
with those trees it's not going to be a
solid canopy
by the looks of things but i yeah i
wouldn't mind looking at the um
plan again just to with that in mind and
i i think it's
quite an important part of this
application
um well let's certainly kind of just ask
there's a recommendation in there about
removing trees from gardens is that the
case we're not going to have trees in
the gardens or
is it as per the plan where some have
[Applause]
okay
can i just ask if the trees fail who's
do they have to be um
right okay so that so what's planted is
is gonna you know has to have those
keep growing very cool things can i just
come in on that chair
um so in terms of the landscaping
condition there's a
five or normally a ten year these days a
requirement to replace anything
that fails within that time frame after
ten years there's no obligation
to replace we can't preserve a tree
forever
in that context just looking at the
outline permission the outline secures a
public open space
it doesn't secure what size it should be
that is a matter of the reserve matters
in front of you
i would i'm probably adding my
professional opinion here
in my experience on looking at many many
applications over the years
this is a reasonable size public open
space
um there is
quite it's actually quite big compact
it's considering the size of the actual
development
that it's connected to um and so i offer
my professional opinion that the space
with the number of trees either more
or less is reasonably substantial given
the scale of development
i hate to say i don't think there's a
wrong decision here in the context
that we're discussing but i'll leave
that with members to to debate further
okay well if james is happy with the
more trees option
then we'll stick with that
thank you anybody else like to come in
thank you chair um just a bit of clarity
required if possible and there's a huge
number of
concerns that the place services have
raised on page
22 and 23 are these
all resolved in the condition
from the outline or does there need to
be some further condition
on this current permission
so you're talking about things like
fibrous trees and stuff yeah there's a
whole
load of different sort of little bitty
bits where they've
they've sort of picked holes in what
what's been
what's been proposed i'm not quite sure
how those are all resolved
so in addition to the um
two option landscaping plans um they
tend to deal with everything that we can
see
within the plants we've also got a
landscape management and maintenance
schedule as well
so everything about sort of planting mix
we've got native species in there
we've got things appropriate to um
to the area and you know our feature
trees are sort of things like oaks and
and things that sort of would be found
within the landscape there and then we
have the rest of the detail provided
within the
plan the actual um outline requires that
the
details of the landscaping to come in i
think we have a condition
um recommended at the end of the report
that talks about
landscape management and enhancement so
that additional plan would then speak
to to that detail
so so they would all be resolved or
the majority of your results the
majority have already been resolved
within
the plans that before you the only one
that wouldn't be is the one that speaks
to
the amount of trees on the on the piece
of public open space
if you chose to go with option b
okay
yep sorry to keep dipping in but it does
follow on from what councilor casten
said about
that the mismatch of the sun and the
need for heat
of course this the paragraph before
paragraph 150
in the mpf deals with this this is the
other extreme
is too much heat i mean what i see on
the plans on 104
is is a completely south-facing glazed
elevation
i see no screening or shade on this uh
therefore on a day like today the
reverse will be true there'll be no need
for central heating
and there'll be masses of passive solar
gain coming in through that glass
so we'll probably have to have at least
forced ventilation
requiring more power or at worst even
air conditioning
because of the orientation and design
thank you thank you and conversely of
course they won't need the heating on so
it's it's this is it's a nightmare isn't
it because it's it's 50 50 on both
um i think we're coming to the end of
debate actually i think everybody's been
given the opportunity to speak
um i'm a fan of bee and the reason for
that is because
we spend lots of time in this council
chamber arguing there aren't enough
trees we're not planting enough here we
are with a plan that promotes more trees
and we're
arguing against that it's very difficult
um and all the points are relevant
uh but we do have a proposal we do have
a second day and i am going to move to
the vote
so therefore i'll ask the area planning
manager to read out the proposal
including the conditions on the table
uh before we go to a vote if it's okay
mr pemgr i've got that because i've put
it into the vote chair
um so if i read out what is in the vote
for this
full member so the application dc 2100
755 be approved as detailed in the
office of recommendation
with option b of the landscaping scheme
being chosen
and the additional conditions as follows
condition on glazing to be designed for
bird impact avoidance to be agreed by
officers
and notwithstanding details of the west
boundary details of fencing
and landscaping to be agreed by officers
i propose you happy with the readout of
the conditions as well
thank you therefore go for the vote
thank you chair the vote is now in
progress if members could please go to
the plus sign in the top right hand
corner of their agenda
of today's gender and go to the
subsection on voting slash attendance
and then click on the vote that's in
progress that's shown in a light blue
cover
counselor carson can i please take your
vote
thank you for the proposing thank you
so chair all votes have now been
received with cancer carson's vote as
well being taken verbally so that is
four votes four three against and one
abstention
it will show on your mongov as drawn
only because councillor carson's vote
has been taken verbally
i understand that therefore that is
carried thank you
we will take short five minute leg
stretch please fill it glasses of water
and if we come back in let's make it 10
minutes come back in on the hour please
item 7b which is dc2102067
land at black acre hill brownford road
great blakenam in suffolk and i'll ask
the case officer catherine hale
to introduce the application to the
committee catherine
thank you chair and good morning members
so this is a
reserve matters application for a
warehouse
at at blake black acre hill um great
blakenham
also known as port warren logistics
um so i'll see great blakeland's a key
service center the principle of
development has already been established
by a previous outline permission um
and section 73 that was before members
last november so you may briefly recall
the history for this one so the late
papers just to remind you that
originally in the report
it was concluded by officers that the
banding the coloured boarding should be
changed upon further discussion with the
agent
um we're actually in agreement that the
colour cladding should remain
as per the existing unit this already in
erected unit 4
with the light boarding at the bottom
working its way up to the darker
boarding
within this slideshow a couple slides
later i'll go on to explain why we've
decided that actually it's
better to keep that existing theme
and and go against kind of what the
parish council are looking for
so this is a site location plan you can
see on the screen
the unit unit 3 here this is the one
we're looking at today
unit 4 has already already been approved
and is built and actually occupied at
present
so this is you'll see the aerial map of
the wider site
and then this is just obscene context
with
great blake and itself to the north so
oasis would be
over here this development coming
forwards
there aren't any constraints within the
site
again this is just a close-up shot of
the layout um the access has already
been agreed via the outline
and the amended section 73
these are the proposed elevations so
the the land slopes from the from the
road and gradually goes
northward upwards and this proposal is
seeking to erect
a building that will be 19 meters above
the finish floor level
unit 4 which it will sit behind
is approximately
i think 20 22 or 23
meters above so this will sit in this um
in the street scene a lot lower
this is just a laid out imagery to show
we'll see the star as a con is a sight
and the green arrows just show where the
land starts to rise because it's within
within a valley
so the red indicates the main up
close-up views of the site that you'll
get from the road
so this is existing frontage and you can
see in the background
um bolton waste here
which is to the north of the site i'll
see the the buildings will
be here behind this existing screening
again this just demonstrates the
proposed planting on the right
so there's an element outside the red
line plan which
from a previous image shows all the
existing hedgerow
and also within the site they're
proposing additional landscaping
and screening
this is basically the elevation
obviously on my previous plans it shows
against white background so the
warehouse does look quite stark
however it will actually appear
behind trees so i should get to it
it will actually appear in the visual
landscape
similar to this we'll see this is a
mock-up but you'll only see the very
tops of the warehousing
again this is just a view so this slide
goes to
show the differences in the um color
boarding
so on the left hand side you can see
with a darker color on top
and on the right you can see where it's
got the lighter color um
originally in my report the committee
report it was recommended that lighter
goes on top within these close-up views
you can understand the rationale behind
that because it blends in with the sky
whereas the dark does tend to stick out
however that is
purely from the junction and
therefore when you look at it from a
wide escape this is a long view so you
can see
the um the kind of pale boarding
where it sits so you'd it would be more
obvious if the lighter boarding was at
top compared to the darker
whereas here you can see it kind of
blends in so i'll just go back
so that would be if it was light at the
top and that would be if it was dark it
blends into the existing
treescape also just the context of waste
building
is obviously dark grays at the top
and another you know surrounding site it
would fit
in terms of drainage there is at the
moment are holding objection
from suffolk county council floods
because they don't believe there's
enough drainage within the red line site
plan
whilst that's noted this whole this
application is also being brought
forward in phases
there are other phases and the existing
outline and subsequent section 73
followed by an extension to the port one
site
which again has already been before
members last year and has been approved
encompasses a wider site-wide
drainage strategy where where it you
know there is considered to be
sufficient
suds drainage furthermore the section 73
and outline had conditions on it
and i believe there is a doc and at the
moment you'll see
discharge the the suds and the drainage
system
um therefore the recommendation is grant
with a couple of conditions but a lot of
the conditions have again previously
been dealt with by the
section 73
thank you catherine um so to say well
done on the slide presentation i think
the
the movement there slide 15 onwards
really helped sort of bring things to
light so that that was that was really
good thank you
are there any questions please for the
case officer councillor stringer
wrong one sorry kevin can you just go
over that
color thing again because i understand
what you're saying but
it went quite quickly and for me the
trees disappeared
into sort of a grey merc if i could look
at that again that would be most helpful
yeah that's fine
so these ones yeah okay so this is a
long distance view
um i do believe in the late papers that
were provided to members there was a
couple more comprehensive issues and
and it did um pictures sorry and it did
explain
the change but you can just about see
there's a kind of white strip
along here this would be the the color
of unit free
if we were to go with the current um
condition that i've i've suggested where
the the light boarding
which i think is known as an oyster um
oyster color
it is on the top so you can just about
with the unit for you just about see it
above the tree line
but the darker gray at the top here um
is obviously where the existing unit
four is
so you'd have the existing uniform dark
gray and then you'd suddenly have a
white
or a lighter color of boarding along
here
um followed by the trees so if you have
it dark
you can kind of the image isn't in great
in the sense that
we we'll kind of discuss this last
minute so it's not
a cgi sort of image but you can see the
strip
just along here so it just blends in
completely with uniform
i'll just go back again if you just kind
of look can you see ever so slightly
so when when looking from a longer view
when the darker boarding's on top
as previously agreed for unit 4 it
blends into
into the wider sort of unit behind the
waste incinerator plant to the left
there
and kind of the trees and existing
vegetation
just come back on it yeah sure surely if
it were lighter at the top
the light would blend in with the sky
as does the because the energy from
waste plant that elevation there is not
a dark boarding
that's a reflective metal surface
so i think that is that not the point
that the depends which thing you're
contrasting it with doesn't it
uh and and i and i would have imagined
if it were lighter there's a there's a
lighter band to the right of those trees
i'll take it that's a roof
um that that will be the there's more um
aussie units to come forward as part of
further reserve matters
um for the previous extension to the
site under dc
20 0 1175 which was granted earlier in
the year
that proposes another number of units
which will eventually
sit in the landscape along here um
and therefore if if this color
option where the light at the top is
then brought for the whole site
and you'd see it on all the units
because obviously you're not going to
keep changing the
pattern of boarding each time a unit
comes forward then you'd also have the
white line
all along across there the argument is
that then
yes close up it blends into the sky but
from a from a longer view
the white here you can see is quite a
contrast compared to if it was dark
okay so and you'll see with the the
waste and injury although it is
reflective it's reflective and the
you know this this boarding option is
cladding
and it's a colored cladding so it offers
no reflective purpose
okay any other questions because having
thank you um so um although um jason has
a holding objection you're saying that's
all been conditioned in
previously so it's all yeah yeah so it's
being conditioned as
part of both the existing
outline of section 73 on this particular
site
and then the extended part it's also
been conditioned and the whole point is
it's a wider
sustainable drainage system in place
it's not just purely for
this unit it affects all all units and
it's been conditioned
i believe that the oc is in at the
moment um i think
suffolk floods have asked for some more
information so it's not quite ready to
be discharged but we're working on it
and also as soon as they're happy
it will get discharged so for this
purpose and versus application we're
content that
it's acceptable
another questions thank you um
okay so moving on to public speakers we
don't have a representative from the
parish
an objector or a supporter so i'll now
ask the applicant an agent to speak
nick davey and maxwell hembree you have
three minutes between you
to address the committee please let me
know when you're about to start
uh thank you members um i'm going to
take the three minutes up mr hembree is
here in case uh you have any questions
for the
for the developer um so uh
what your officer said is that uh
correctors you have a reserve matters
application before you today
for the second unit of port one now the
tenant is signed up
and if permission is granted contracts
worth over 9.8 million
will be placed this week with a view to
getting on site and completing that
building in early 2022
and once it's completed there'll be 250
people employed there
and that will add to the 150 within unit
4.
as agreed with the council the junction
onto brantford road
and the electric shuttle bus are on
course to be in place before the end of
the year before unit 3 opens
we've also agreed to make a seven figure
investment
so that ways from the adjacent waste to
energy plant
can be converted into power and brought
onto the park
and that schema will create another 250
jobs
and that initiative complements the
photovoltaic cells on the roofs of the
buildings
the use of low energy lighting and the
installation of some electric vehicle
charging points with agreed by the
biodiversity enhancements and the
planting of what will eventually be over
two thousand
trees port one when completed will be
one of the most sustainable and green
logistics parks in the uk
um we submitted a number of applications
to get this scheme off the ground
phase three as your officers said we
have an application to discharge the
drainage condition
um that's been discussed now and
drainage isn't technically before you as
part of this
reserve matters application but the
whole site covers 25 hectares
we have more than sufficient land to
create a solution
and that will be forthcoming we've also
discussed the other matter that sort of
cropped up in the last few days has been
the banding
of the colours um from the very outset
we started discussing this with the
council in 2013 and from the very outset
one of the council's key objectives was
to make sure that this scheme sat well
in long-distance views particularly when
seen from the other side of the valley
so the scheme the buildings are cut into
the landscape
to make sure that they are all lower
than the trees and the land behind it
when seen from the eastern side of the
valley
they what they are not seen against sky
from that point of view
none of the buildings are they're seen
against the trees and that's why the
dark color at the top works
and that image that we have a long
distance view that shows you unit four
the one that's been constructed and that
really blends in and from the clayton's
side you can hardly see that building
um so we're convinced i mean we can do
the banding either way
if members want it the other way we'll
do it that way but we're convinced that
the original rationale
agreed in this chamber or your previous
chamber is the right
approach and it is better to protect the
long-distance views and mitigate the
impact on the wider landscape
that's particularly as there aren't that
many uh local views it really is around
that junction that's the only place
you'll see
the buildings against the sky to quickly
summarize we're at three minutes
so to summarize um following the
completion of unit 4 and the
announcement that port 1 is now part of
freeport east we are experiencing
unprecedented demand
for the site virtually every unit is now
signed up
so if you grant consent for this one we
will be back in a few months with
the rest of the phases this scheme
should be something hopefully everyone
can be proud of
thank you um so committee do you have
any questions for the agents
yeah castlefield
[Music]
yes thank you um just uh you made a
comment about the
uh an agreement with the energy from
waste plant
i didn't quite catch what you said i
wonder if you could explain that to us
more fully and some disappointment as a
local member and
i don't know anything about that and
neither does the parish council
can i refer to the developer mr maxwell
henry
we have a ongoing discussion at the
moment with
um suez who obviously worked for suffolk
county council
and there are certain confidentiality
agreements that we've had to sign for
that
but it's always been the intention to
use the power that's available under a
private wire arrangement which is up to
10 meg
and we have committed to them that we
will be paying for all of the
infrastructure costs that take that
power into the site
to be able to provide low-cost
energy directly across from the waste to
energy plant into our site
and that is a seven-figure sum which we
have told that we will be paying for
thank you kelseyfield thank you
um council casting
thank you mr chairman could i ask a
further question that
when would that be tapped into what
would be the plan to um
connect that
at the moment we're in discussions to
try and sort out
the design of the scheme but
i think we've got an interested
party in terms of the exporter of the
power because it makes sense to them it
doesn't have to go into the grid and get
eroded away
it's less efficient plus the fact that
there's an
added benefit for them because they get
extra revenue into the county and we're
talking
you know seven figure some every year
and um
as far as our occupiers are concerned
they're very very keen to use that power
because there's considerable saving
because
if you look at your average electricity
bill it's
roughly about a third of it is the
generating cost
the rest of it is taxes by importing it
directly into the site
the producer gets more money and the
user makes a saving
it's a win-win situation for everybody
for for the next 20 years hopefully
thank you any other questions
okay in that case so we're going to move
to the award member which is uh
councillor
field now council phil
[Music]
thank you obviously pleased to hear that
development
um i was just going to point out that
the
outline approval which is established
the principle of development on black
acre hill
for employment use was based on the
access to the
a14 the site enjoys that's a short
about 680 metre stretch of dual
carriageway
um the adjacency to other industrial
plant for instance the energy from waste
plant
and the low number of dwellings that are
adjacent to the site there's
about seven within 120 meters the rest
are a lot
further away clearly that established
the principle
that uh development here was was fully
acceptable
and i wouldn't reach to challenge that
in any way
however there were a few points in the
report that
somewhat surprised me and i just if i
can run through those
um to an extent because there's sort of
things that occur in many of our reports
i was somewhat surprised that the regard
given to the spawn neighborhood plan
we want noble plans taken into account
but that parish is separated from great
blackening by little bikini
and bradford and it's some 3.7
kilometers different
distance from this proposed development
so i don't see the relevance the
presence of a
designated enterprise area in sport is
noted but i could find no re
and for instance in your report uh
that port one is now part of the felix
stone heritage freeport which
seems somewhat important however
i say it was going to say i'm pleased to
see the comments of the parish council
been considered
for the colour scheme um and i now hear
that's no longer true as of yesterday or
so
and i have no go axe to grind on that
point
other than it's something one should
communicate to local people
if they understand why you're doing it
you don't get resistance and we could
all do with less resistance to planning
applications
i feel the holding objection from scc
flood water management who are a highly
competent
team appears somewhat to be dismissed
and i hope the committee will
investigate that judgment
ensure that it's justified the second
paragraph on page 116
shouldn't be ignored scc highways make
no comment on the congestion that
currently occurs at the cain junction
with the a14
an opportunity that was ignored at the
outline stage and one which will no
doubt return to haunt local road
users as port one site is fully
developed
valley ridge holiday facility and ski
slope generates considerable villagers
and employer traffic presumably it's too
late to take any action today but
i think that's still an issue of regret
the heritage team make no comment and
the report indicates no listed
buildings nearby however mid-suffolk
mapping shows four
which have employment uses within 270
metres and i think they're on the map on
page
on slide five the recommendation of
place
services for a condition involving
landscape details
does not appear to have been followed
through i couldn't see it in the list of
recommendations i'd also say the
arguments of paige
are in 11.1 to 11.5
the impact of the development on the
residential community is not just ever
significant it appears to me strained
this is clearly a major building close
to
wellings that have previously enjoyed
and
essentially rule out look and it's
difficult to accept that
the proposal will not affect the privacy
of nearby properties nor their visual
immunities
however the definitive residential
immediate
maintenance he produced should be
balanced against the wider advantages of
the site
and i feel i accepted that that this is
a reasonable choice
the requirements for the noise
management plan is clearly appropriate
although it will be difficult to deliver
acceptable noise levels
with the impact of reserve reversing
bleepers considered
however i do hope that that condition
that that requirement in
in the approval if you choose to go that
way
is strong and enforceable
um i would also say
on the affordable on the um
solar energy point of view that we
appear in in
certainly my uh count my um
district ward to be set on converting
hundreds of acres of farmland to
to to soda farm purposes and i wondered
whether we're actually taking advantage
of the uh
considerable area of roof that exists in
in this development which is actually
orientated south and whether we're
making full advantage of that
um as a if you like free acreage that we
can use
and just to summarize therefore in
principle i support the application for
reserve
matters approval as does the parish
council
providing the conditions which you place
on
on the application include those that
come from our consultants
all of the ones from our consultants
i would wish the highways condition
issues be addressed
but i'm sure and i'm sure that to hope
for that is fantasy
thank you thank you councilfield
any questions for the war member please
okay in that case uh let's open up for
debate he's going to start
council casting
thank you very much mr chairman i think
there's a huge amount of benefits
from this i am i like the ideas of jobs
in the region um i like the idea that it
could become one of the greenest
industrial states in the uk i think
that's some
fantastic um with the tree planting
um i don't think
the cladding is the right way around
personally
i think um lighter at the top would be
um
would mitigate the um visual impact of
this
quite substantially um the
the biggest impact of this i think is
from the
b treble 1 3 i know we can look at the
from the surrounding area but
there will be far more people going past
on the b treble one three
and um a the angle that they'd be
looking up at this that white
cladding at the top i think would
mitigate that
impact hugely um i'm from around that
area enough
a lot of people have um said on social
media that they um
they think it is the wrong way around
but i think that's something that
maybe we can talk about later the um
when this came round the um
for outline i think we had this solar
panel
conversation and we were told that
because there wasn't a huge amount of
consumption
it didn't need solar panels all over it
so um
correct me if i'm wrong but i do
remember that um
that being um that statement being made
the um
so i do think we're missing a um
a trick with solar panels but i do
understand that this has
a a really unique um
energy um connection to a um
energy from waste center which is
fantastic
like not wasting money through the grid
is fantastic
but with the solar panels i do think
that um we've got a massive area there
that could be utilized
and um it does just seem like the uh
you know the right thing to do um but
that's for counselors to um
discuss but um apart from that yeah
i think this is a really sensible um
development in the right place in the
freeport
and economically for the area
for jobs and you know just
even even just um like reducing
transport
distances and um from ports and things i
think it's um
yeah i think it's really good but i will
just leave those points with councillors
for um debate the um the cladding which
way around that should um
be and maybe the um solar
issue thank you council casting um i'm
sure
miss pope mcgee will come in if i'm
wrong but i don't believe in the reserve
matters that solar panels could be
part of it
could i ask actually the case officer
just to comment on that because
you're more aware of what's actually
going on there yeah so i believe
that the there will be um a photovoltaic
roof
um that i don't know what that is for
this unit
i don't know whether it will be for
other units coming forward i presume it
would be
um but yeah any questions over solar
panels is probably best directed to the
agent but i'm pretty sure that
they're part of it for this unit but in
terms
of conditioning that extra bit of
proposal under reserve matters
application no chair to be consistent
obviously with the application we just
dealt with uh
we not something we'd say is connected
to the
appearance and layout and scale of
what's before members
correct i'm pretty sure it's not part of
of reserve matters
the agent if you could give us some
information on that that'd be really
welcome actually
size of them the um electricity drawer
isn't
you know as you would expect um there
are
solar panels on the roof you have a roof
plant drawing showing them
uh it's been submitted with the reserve
matters application
and that is sufficient to power a good
part of the
intelligent lighting scheme within the
building um
low voltage and the lights in every i'll
turn off so there's no activity in the
aisle no one's going to pick the stock
the lights go off after one minute and
then they're on sensors and come on
so everything is being done to keep the
power to the minimum and on the original
outline application there is a
sustainability condition which includes
uh
provision and implementation of resource
energy resource measures
that is in with the council now so sort
of today
rails would really be part of that
discussion rather than the reserve
matters
yeah agreed and um just the council
casting
obviously the addition of solar panels
that's outside of this so it is what it
is
council stringer yes chad that was the
point i was going to make the original
outline would have had a condition
to provide an element of solar panels on
this roof
beyond that that's a commercial decision
according to our policies
even though we may wish it and it would
make absolutely common sense to do so
because yeah if you're really building a
room and at the end of the day
get your point but at least 10 of the
power consumption should
should be from solar within your outline
permission
perfect thank you so clear on that
council casting
so just the point i was making in
outline we were told 10
would be put on there and that was
enough to cover the energy and i just
i feel i feel like um maybe that was a
little bit misleading
outline and it's something that we might
have to look at
in the future the um sorry i do have
another
point there's some this drainage
situation
um if that next phase
didn't get built would we be able to um
have a bond
in place to make sure if say the worst
came to the worst and that last phase
couldn't be done for whatever reason
could we have a bond in place to make
sure that drainage is acceptable for
that
development that is not within your
power or scope
of the application before you um can i
just come back on the 10
i'm assuming the 10 on the original
outline was based on the
policy cs3 which talks about 10
decentralized energy that's where that
10 comes from
thank you
yeah i believe that was the case thank
you
okay anybody else for debate castle
warboys
thank you chair uh
sorry tangled up here
too many things on my ears um i'd just
like to thank the officer actually for
the the care which she's
taken over looking at the um aesthetics
of the
the buildings i agree with the the
officer and the developer that
that the dark band at the top would be
the better
solution uh the reason in it
for me is that um it's from some
these are large buildings it's not going
to be possible to sort of mitigate the
size from every possible angle
and possibly looking at it from the
distance
will be is the better approach um
as for looking at it from the side of
the road i think possibly you shouldn't
be looking up at the buildings as you go
past
so the the close the closer views
um maybe aren't that significant
um but i i also think this is a you know
i really welcome that
we're having popular um employment
buildings coming forward and these are
popular
uh from the point of people moving in so
the visual coherence of the site is
really
important aesthetically this is a very
well considered
industrial site and there's a lot of
thought going into the
landscaping and the there's points in
here about
biodiversity and provision for plant
boxes i think
the coherence of the site is really
important which i think for me is
tilts the balance in favor of having the
dark band at the top
as regards the photoelectric cells i
think possibly the occupants of the
buildings would be missing the
trick if they didn't fit photoelectric
cells on every
south-facing surface possible um
but that's that's a matter for the for
future occupants
but those are my good points thank you
councillor
um thanks um i've listened to what
debate there has been and
my opinion is that it's a very good very
well thought out
um application and i'm happy to propose
that we agree
um go along with the officer's
recommendation
so take that's a proposal okay proposal
for recommendation of approval
do you have a secondary council war boys
thank you anybody else wish to enter
debate
cool so one of my jobs in the military
was a cat surveillance instructor and it
was all about camouflage
and it does seem a little bit odd that
we have green at the top and i'm like
when i first saw it i'm like i just
can't get my head around this that's mad
disguise blue
but it is all about the valley and it's
all about backdrop
you can have a warship and you can be
right against it and you'll see it
go 15 miles back and come slightly up
with backdrop it disappears
and it's the same principle here it's
about the backdrop it's about proper
camouflage
i i really do commend you guys for doing
such an excellent job in my opinion
on that and also on your environmental
um
approach to this this is probably one of
the best industrial sort of warehouse
areas that i've seen come across
while i've been in planet so well done
um
yeah happy days any other points
okay let's go to the governance officer
then go for an electronic vote
thank you chair so the vote is laid out
as follows is the application dt2102067
be approved
as detailed in the office of
recommendation
so if members could please go to the
modern.gov app and go to the plus sign
in the top right hand corner of today's
agenda
they will bring up the subsection of
attendance voting and will show in a
light
blue color that's the casting can i
please take your vote verbally
thank you for thank you counselor
would you like me to take your vote
verbally counselor
so chair that's all votes now received
with council hattingham accounts the
cast has been taken verbally
that's eight votes also is unanimously
carried
thank you that is carried
is everybody happy that we continue on
to the next um
okay nobody needs a short break chair we
just need to do a bit of
musical chat yeah we'll take five
minutes in place please while we just
sort things out
welcome back everybody we now move to 7c
which is dc2100641
which is land to the east of turkey hall
lane backed in suffolk
and i'll now ask the case officer alex
scott to introduce the application to
the committee alex
hey thank you chairman um yes members
uh chairman's just stated this is gender
item 7c application dc
21.00641 land to the east of turkey hall
lane
in backton the application before you is
reserved mata's application for the
layout scale appearance
and landscaping relating to the erection
of 51 dwellings
including 18 affordable houses in public
open space
the principle of which and matters of
access
which were formally agreed by committee
in may of
2018
and we'll move on to the presentation
this is the location of back um back
then within
the district for the avoidance of doubt
everybody
and the general location of the site
within the village
this is a constraints plan of the site
as the site extends to
approximately 3.52 hectares
and would include approximately 1.13
hectares of public open space
gives a net density of 21.8
dwellings per hectare as is mentioned in
the top of
your report um
so the the main constraints of the site
the site lies outside of the village
settlement boundary as indicated by the
blue line
on the plan which is on the screen at
the moment
and the blue indicating that bacton is a
key service center settlement in the
current plan
and as mentioned in the uh in the report
um the principle has already been uh
established by way of the outlying
uh permissions so um yes that is
not a uh consideration for today
we're on matters of layout scale
appearance of buildings and landscaping
only
just to just to be clear and
the main planning constraints affects
the setting of a
grade two listed building a turkey hall
which is
uh in orange i'll try and put the laser
there so that is turkey hall and uh it's
curtilage
grade two listed and the main
disc two uh stone market railway line
runs uh adjacent to the site
there so that is what that that
line is there and then there's there's
quite a low um
low bridge low bridging point which uh
cars
must pass under on pound hill
in this direction so larger vehicles uh
the access would be like turkey hall
lane
and clay lane exiting just off the
screen
there so those are the uh
main constraints of the of the site
this is an aerial map um
just showing the uh what it looks like
in photograph form
unless around
this is the site location plan or the
red line site plan submitted
with the application
this is the overall layout um now
please note that this is revision p18
uh which differs to the uh layout
ever so slightly i would stress that
it is different to the one in your in
your papers and this was submitted by
the applicant
in response to uh comments received
from county highways which is again in
the late papers
of uh of your reports so we have this
plan and
um those comments from highways in the
report so
this is in response to uh the highways
comets and really what the
um or the applicant has included in this
later
excuse me go back to that there we go
um was the addition of a footpath here
and highways have raised concerns that
there was no
um no footpath uh through the site
for those wishing to walk up turkey hall
lane to the north so that's the reason
for the
inclusion of that and that has now been
included um just for information those
um wishing to walk south
of the site the idea is
that that would be through north close
which is here
has established footpaths and hence the
connecting footway which is proposed in
this location
and um yeah it's hoped that the majority
of
people would follow that established
paid footpath network to avoid turkey
hall lane which
does have an absence of um of footways
that presence that's the reasons
behind that um now public open space
is uh in uh in what three principal
locations
really we have either side of the
proposed access here and
adjacent to the existing playground
which is this
this blank area just outside the site
here with connections through
and
that totals 1.3 hectares approximately
as per my measurements and there are
also
other open areas here which are
in tandem with the scheme of surface
water drainage sustainable surface water
drainage which has been
considered and approved by our
consultants in suffolk county council
the local flood authority and
these drainage basin features included
within the
public open space part of that
you know is visual immunity primarily
and uh they do not need to be fenced um
they are
of a of a gradient and depth which
does not need treatment um and
that has been considered an agreed um by
southern county council uh floods and
drainage and
um and by um
by our uh excuse me
yeah by our public realm team who are uh
happy with the landscaping schedule and
maintenance plan as proposed
so um that has been checked out by our
uh
[Applause]
so um moving on i have a closer
map this is the western portion or the
southwest portion of the site
and we already
talked about the public open space
adjacent to the playground which is
again in this this area
with a link through
and yes boundary treatments
now there was a bit of concern raised by
consultees with
um at the top of north close with we've
got
regards what boundary treatment was to
be provided now there is a boundary
treatment plan submitted with
the application and what that states is
that
bandage treatments in this location this
location onto the public open space
and the the view and aspect
from existing properties it would be a
a low 1.4 meter
post and rail arrangement um just to
define the boundary
but then that allows a uh
some amenities some outlook for existing
properties
and has the additional benefit of
surveillance
so the um existing properties would look
out to
the public open space um hoping to um
survey that um keep an eye out
from a um a secure by design perspective
as well
so i think that's beneficial
and then we have the uh
the eastern portion of the northeast
portion if you if you will
and predominantly the market dwellings
in this location
now i will point out there are a few
instances of
uh triple parking um in the top of the
site but
um that's all been assessed from uh by
county highways who are
um happy with the the layout which has
been provided and as it's at the top of
the uh
the cul-de-sac and not part of the uh
the main arterial
road arrangement it's considered
acceptable
in in that location so
no objections from your offices on that
although that
that point is is noted
this is the affordable housing layout
now they're indicated by
um by blue uh here
and we have um
[Music]
ten flats uh split into two buildings
one here and one here
and four pairs of semi-detached
uh dwellings as well um so that
amounts to the 18 affordable units
proposed now there has been a bit of uh
concern raised by
um uh some uh
representations and indeed um your own
strategic housing officers on the on the
on the clustering
of the uh of the dwellings and
concerned that they're not pepper potted
as it
as the term commonly used is
now reasons behind this are
are in terms of maintenance and keeping
the types of
dwellings together i think it's your
officer's consideration that it's a
uh the dwellings are not bunched up in a
corner you know they've got a
you know good aspects onto public open
space you know very generously um
sized open spaces and surroundings um
you know a nice a nice environment we
feel so
we feel the uh the layout is
is acceptable in that regard and
provides a good standard immunity of uh
future occupants particularly the uh
occupants of the affordable dwelling so
we're
generally comfortable with that and
whilst comments are noted
we don't feel that a um a refusal or
um an appeal could be sustained on
on that basis so that is our
recommendation to you today
uh on to the proposed elevations this
these are the
market dwellings so we have 33
market dwellings proposed in total
throughout the site we have
the seven design variations as shown on
the plan there
a mix of two three and four bedroom
dwellings um
whoops i keep doing that apologies
um and uh 10
10 bungalows uh proposed
and no false chimneys members will note
so hopefully that's uh
to everybody's taste um
now these are the affordable housing
houses proposed 18 in total
as you can see there there will be six
buildings
uh a mix of flats and semi-attached
dwellings and a mix of
one two and three bedroom properties
in the variety shown there
and the garages uh which will go
alongside
27 of the uh of the dwellings
uh proposed four design variations
as you can see the majority being
the top uh double garage and
uh and the bottom one of single garages
as well
with just one a plot three with a middle
design
oh i should say the garages are um
they're they're parking compliant they
are compliant with um
sec parking standards so they could be
used um and have
indeed been counted um as as parking
spaces
in terms of the uh the layout and
parking provision
this is the uh the treatment proposed to
the
the foul pumping station
which will be as a
detailed plan here of its location so
adjacent to the
surface water drainage and we have the
the listed cartilage in this location
so your heritage officers um
certainly had an interest in this this
structure in particular
indeed their first response did ask for
this additional detail which the
applicant has provided
in their um ensuring response which is
provided for you in the late papers
they're generally satisfied with the uh
the approach um the uh the the the brick
arrangement screening
um which is proposed and uh the
uh the view which we would get
from uh from turkey hall the list of
buildings
screened for my existing hedging but
heritage have asked for
additional details um as set out in
their latest response
which has led to an amended
recommendation
in in the late papers um just um
subject to additional conditions as
required by your heritage officers
as well so just a minor amendment to the
recommendation including
including that for you there
on to the street scenes so um
the street scenes are shown in
uh in this in this plan here
uh we have uh street scene
number one which would uh look
uh in this direction and that is the the
bottom view
here we have street scene two which is
looking
in a northerly direction along this
elevation that's the long one
across the top there for you and street
scene
three looking from the public open space
an existing playground
that is the the middle bar here so
that's
that's approximately what you would see
there
and then finally number four which is
the affordable housing
uh from from the first branch road here
opposite to the street scene one there
and this uh for the information
is the layout which was uh
presented the indicative layout at
outline stage
um which as you can see it's is
somewhat different as a comparison
so we had um a much more yet
all all exit in one basket really with
the public open space
a much larger site was proposed
it's now proposed to split that up into
uh various locations as you can see on
the uh
the layout before you today um
and um yeah it's a view of your officers
public open space officers as well that
uh
yes it's more um appropriate pleasing to
do it in this way
and gives a you know benefits to the
setting of
uh of the scheme um to the street scene
a much more softer approach to turkey
hall lane itself
and um yes
you know it gives gives give greater
access across the site for residents to
um to to the various public open spaces
uh and amenities uh available so uh
i get it considered acceptable by your
uh by your officers i think in
conclusion
um on to some uh artistic drawings
which have recently been provided by the
applicants and these just
show um yeah gives you a sense of um
what the character would be of the uh of
the housing estate
uh to be provided so yeah quite open
green trees uh backdrop of countryside
and existing and proposed public open
space
onto some photographs for you um
now this first one is at the top of
turkey hall lane
and the junction of of pound hill
and then moving down turkey hall lane
and we can see the beginning of the site
here
and this is the uh the far end of the
site and you might be able to see turkey
hall
the listed building in in the background
now turning round and looking back down
uh turkey hall lane
the existing uh properties here
which will uh front onto the uh publicly
open space to the
front edge of the of the site
and just a view
across the site to conclude
okay that concludes the presentation um
as per
your papers uh officer recommendation
for approval with
uh those conditions as per the
amended recommendation in the table
papers
thank you very much chairman thank you
uh do you have any questions for the
case officer council stringer uh i was i
was hoping you were going to show
pictures of the footpath link that you
alluded to
and how people would walk from this site
to the footpath network
sorry i don't have any photographs you
mentioned the footpath network through
north close yes i don't have any
photographs i think that was
illustrated on the map yes i think so so
bring the map back up please
sorry so um yes the linking footpath
uh from the footpath network proposed
that is not there at
the moment and linking it to the top of
uh north close
and then connecting through thank you
it's precisely when your cursor is there
that that area there would be really
interesting for members to know what
that is
so can you explain it because obviously
i haven't got a photograph what does it
lead into uh what it leads into um
as far as i could uh conceal and
remember the
the top of the uh of the cul-de-sac and
uh the existing uh road network and pave
network which
leads to pound help you would have to
cross pound
hill at some points but uh as do
existing uh residents it's
certainly safer than um coming down
turkey hall lane
your officers thing so cancer what we'll
do when it comes to the agent we'll ask
that question
okay yes councilman yeah thank you
a couple of questions um the ah
we're useful to have that back up sorry
randy
um the the the area of open space on the
of right hand side there which is
probably the biggest chunk of open space
i'm not clear how that is sort of
surveyed by
the other houses around it because it
appears to be the back
of the houses at the top right and then
a sort of side
from one of the other houses it doesn't
appear to be very well
surveilled the other question i have is
at the bottom you've got your existing
uh built form
at the end of north close how close is
the
the nearest new dwelling or new building
to the to the existing it looks very
close there
uh yes just just picking up the uh the
distance
i measure it to be um approximately five
meters from the um
from the maps provided um now um
i'm not sure how entirely accurate it
would be but um
yeah those elevations uh which would
directly face to each other we're um
yeah we're generally satisfied there
wouldn't be a significant
impact on existing residential immunity
there our opinion
um in terms of the uh the open space
uh at the uh to the yes to the east of
the site
i believe it's that uh area um casamayor
was
referring to um yes not not as
um not as surveyed as um as
as the ones to the to the frontage um
but then um but
i would say neither is the existing
playground to the south
and um
there would be a bit of uh surveillance
from
um people uh traversing the site and um
it's uh yeah it's
indicated that it would be well used so
um that's uh
yeah no no significant concerns raised
in that in that aspect but i you know i
do appreciate that um
it's not as surveyed as
the ones at the front
yes thank you um the um
provision of the open space the uh
the new provision i believe you
mentioned was it three and a half
hectares
in size
one point one three hectares there sorry
sorry sorry
1.13 hectares
for the three principle i measure it to
be from the plans provided
okay so the initial the initial off
uh layout was about three and a half
there
um and then no i i
uh you're referring to the indicative
layout at outline
yes the the outline of the showing the
open spaces the one on the
the 2018 version and
it's the the new proposed open spaces
is less than half that
um in that location yes but it's um
there's there has been some uh moved to
the other locations
yes yes yes yes yes
so we're not putting all our eggs in one
basket with no i've just
wondered about that the size of that
specific space to give me an idea of
scale relative to the rest of the
buildings well we can go back to the uh
the plans um if that gets you uh gives
you an idea
that's the one where your dot is that's
about three acres so therefore
comparison uh outline on the left
and uh what's proposed on the right so
the
current proposal is an open space of
about three acres
uh i'm not sure of the acreage counselor
but um i can tell it's 1.13
hectares i'm not sure how that converts
but
thank you yeah i'm not sure if we're in
metric or
imperial at the moment we've got some
farmers that can help out he's not
okay uh any other questions please kel's
having him
oh thank you can you sleep this up sorry
what was um
i was just looking at i'm originally i
appreciate that jason has come back and
has taken away the holding objection
but i was just wondering about his um
safety issues at the
initially because he said they should be
overlooked or something and so i was
wondering what the
difference was but i can just um see on
this map that
so what i'm saying is he was saying that
the the basins
needed to be overlooked and so this is
really what i want him to be looking at
now thank you from the last one
so what i'm saying is that he was saying
initially with the placing of the basins
and i can see
the basins are in the same place but
their housing has changed significantly
so i assume now um
he's happy with that yes
yes indeed yes and um as i said you know
satisfied it doesn't need to be fenced
in any way and
it's considered safe by suffolk candy
council so
that's the information i'm getting
okay looks like we're at the end of that
so um
we don't have an object or a supporter
so i'll ask
the parish representative mr david
david chambers you have three minutes
please let me know when you're about to
start
thank you thank you chairman and good
morning
um afternoon i trust members have had
our detailed comments and it was good to
have the comparative plans
on the screen just now that showed the
difference between the proposal now and
that which we supported at outline in
2018.
we do object though on this occasion as
its variance with the layout and other
undertakings that were given
in that documentation and many of the
concerns of the council express on that
occasion have not been addressed
we're also very disappointed that the
application was submitted without any
prior
public engagement which has been so
successful with other developers that
we've worked with
in the village we were impressed by the
area about usable open space as you've
seen in the outline application
which is anticipated taking to our
ownership for the benefit the whole
village adjacent to saint mary's playing
field
while the application states it includes
provision of a large area of open space
east of the site
as you see it reduces it to less than 50
percent of the area previously
identified
now since mary's playing field which is
the south and been referred to is
leasing the diocese
and is possible in the future this might
go for housing
and so the equivalent area offered
outline would have ensured a continuance
of a similar recreation facility
if such a development took place that
contingency
is now undermined by this application
the layout is significantly different
from the version we saw in 2018
and as we've heard before the affordable
housing cluster together
and the block and the southern boundary
is far too close to the housing
on north close we remain concerned over
vehicles accessing the site from turkey
hall lane
and negotiating its junction with pound
hill and really can't see how the
current roadworks design can achieve
the five and a half meters of highway
along turkey hall lane
and you saw the photographs without
taking more than a meter from current
verges
nevertheless we trust that work will
start before the developments allowed to
commence we've liaised with hawley
parish council in support of their
concerns
about the impact of their village of
construction traffic for this
and the other five vacton sites moving
into construction phase in the next 12
months
we want to see all construction vehicles
that cannot get under our low railway
bridge from the
b triple 1 3 traffic route access the
site via the a140
at the white house then turning right
onto clay lane
where one lay one-way traffic control
should be in operation
and we seek an undertaking no
articulated lorries
will be accessing the site we also
propose that deliveries and removals and
materials from the site
are timed to avoid conflicts with school
drop-offs and collections
both here and in hawley we urge the
committee to reject this design for the
site
and to encourage the developer to engage
with the parish council
on a version including the area of
recreational open space
offered at the outline application stage
thank you thank you
mr james do we have any questions for
the
parish representative
no thank you just bear with me while i
get my page back up
um
again we don't have an object or a
supporter so therefore i'm going to ask
the
agent an applicant applicant to speak
which is ian hill and peter
wapplington again you have three minutes
please let me know when you're about to
start
apologies for that um
accordingly i do not wish to repeat many
of the points that have already been
covered
i would just like to say a few points
about the scheme which if permitted
will enable the delivery of much needed
housing including policy compliant
affordable housing on a committed
development site
as you've already heard flagship are a
registered provider with a track record
of providing high quality residential
developments across east anglia
outline planning permission was granted
in 2008 which secured the principle of
residential development on the site
as well as details of access to the site
including works to turkey hall lane
an indicative layout plan was submitted
with the outline planning application
which showed how the site could
potentially be developed
flagship reappraised the site and its
layout resulting in the creation of a
welcoming electrical and pedestrian
friendly residential development
with a variety of landscaped open spaces
forming key centerpieces throughout the
site
as part of this process rather than a
single large area of open space
that was shown at the outline stage this
has
been split so that rather than providing
one large area a mix of formal and
informal spaces provided throughout the
site
as well as an area to have a kick about
areas of informal green space are
proposed
the importance of a variety of green
space provisions has been highlighted
with all in the last 12 months
in terms of scale and appearance as
highlighted by the images presented by
your officers
the site's low density and landscape-led
approach delivers a spacious and green
residential setting
a high-quality material palette has been
selected and the design of each home has
been carefully considered
the application is accompanied by a
comprehensive landscaping scheme
which includes a significant number of
trees which has been endorsed by the
council's landscape officer
during preparation of the reserve
matters application flagship group
consulted with the parish council prior
to the submission of the application
further post mission engagement has been
undertaken with the parish council which
has led
directly to a number of changes
including the removal of the proposed
community orchard
delivery of more visitor bay parking
bays as well as increased pedestrian
permeability throughout the site
the has received no objections from
technical statutory consultees
including suffolk county council
highways and the local lead flood
authority
whilst comments from residents have
focused on works to turkey hall lane
as commented on earlier access matters
have already been dealt with as part of
the outline planning application
we've noted in early discussions today
the issues relating to sustainability
and particularly the use of renewables
an applica an application to discharge
condition 19 which relates to the
sustainability strategy has been
submitted
and whilst flagship's priority is air
source heat pumps
as part of the discharge of that
condition i think they will be willing
to look at the potential for
fault of attacks in conclusion the
schema for you is one which we believe
represents a high quality sustainable
solution to bring forward a committed
development site
which has undergone significant
consultation with key stakeholders
i therefore respectfully request that
officers approve this application in
accordance with their officer's
recommendation
sorry members approved this application
according to the officer's
recommendation
so the flagship may start delivering
this high quality extension to the
village of bracton
thank you for your time thank you
members uh
thank you and you say you haven't got
any i'm holding objections but you
actually have got one from
our strategic housing team about the um
about all the affordable housing being
together what do you say about that
apologies for that you're actually right
um i think it's been touched on by your
officer is the
point in relation to the pepper potty of
affordable housing across the site
the first point i'd make is as we've
seen with the plans that have been shown
on the screen
the scheme is 10-year blind so you
cannot tell the difference between
affordable and market accommodation in
addition to that i think we have to have
regard to the section 106 agreement
which is attached to the outline
planning commission
that requires that no more than 50 of
the market units can be provided until
50
of the affordable are provided and then
it goes up to no more than 80
of the market accommodation can be
provided to all of the affordable
provided
that requirement as part of the legal
agreement does influence the
construction of the sites
and how it will be developed that is
partly a result of
the the scheme design and the the
location of the affordable units
in addition to that as per the point
that was made by the officer
there are management issues which have
been raised by flagship
which have led to that layout
council girl please
thanks thanks chad and just before i ask
my question that
has previously advised yourself to let
the committee know i would
need to leave just before one o'clock if
we are still
going there absolutely thank you a
simple question really
why no public consultation
in the development of this scheme such
consultation
as the parish represented service is
is very common uh these days and almost
invariably leads to
you know invariably leads to an improved
scheme
i think uh the decision was taken um
that
the public consultation would consist of
a presentation
to the parish council and a meeting was
open to the public
prior to the application being submitted
there had been a substantial amount of
consultation as part of the outline
application
um and then there was further engagement
post submission
can can we confirm that actually took
place
chairman i i don't believe we had such a
public uh consultation on the uh
the question of this application before
us okay thank you
and again we're reserved matters so i'm
surprised it wasn't raised at the
outline
yeah the agent
yeah i think um one of the bases we we
did consult
the parish council and the public at
reserve matters sorry at the outline
application and then when resubmitting
for the reserve matters we reconsulted
the the parish council themselves which
again as um
ian alluded to concluded in has removed
the removal of the orchard and
making more use usable open space for
bacterm parish council
okay thank you happy that uh councillor
string please
just to clarify that that second uh
concentration was via zoo i seem to
remember
it was a virtual consequence it was as
part of the parish council meeting
part of the uh public section of it uh
you alluded to in the original outline
there were works
outlined to turkey hall lane which would
widen it to 5.5 meters
can you clarify that can be done legally
without taking people's private gardens
yes there was a a detail scheme in
relation to the off-site highway works
that required
to deliver the scheme that was agreed as
part of the outline scheme as i said at
the outset as did the officer
access arrangements were approved as
part of the scheme they were agreed with
um with suffolk county council um and
they will go forward as part of a
section 278 agreement will have to be in
place and obviously as part of that
you're absolutely right councillor
they will need to make sure that
flagship or the highway authority are in
control of that land
yeah and and i'd say we've measured it
on the ground and we believe that to be
contrary to the case
so you have measured it on the ground i
take it
because it's so important to there is to
be deliverable
i haven't personally measured it on the
ground okay so we're getting there so i
measured you measured
so we won't go there so we'll bring in
mr patman g and then we'll come back to
you counselor stringer
um yeah this is the first time i've
looked at this outline application i
will admit
and i may require ian to come in if
necessary as i say this
and i probably need alex to
point out if i'm incorrect this is a
very unusual condition
um on number 11 of the outline it's a
very
interestingly worded condition as well
it basically says prior to the first
occupation of dwellings hereby permitted
so as occupation not commencement of the
development
um the works within the public highway
shown on a pacific drawing which is
listed here
shall be designed constructed and
completed in agreement with suffolk
county council
highways there is no provision within
that
for agreement by the district council to
be involved
which is highly unusual for a planning
condition
however essentially it's self-completing
because
that requires the highways works shown
on a specific drawing
at the outline to be constructed
designed and agreed and completed
very importantly an agreement with the
suffolk county highways authority
if there is any alteration necessary to
that drawing
then they will have to go through an
application process to do that
to vary that condition so if that is not
if that drawing is incapable
of going forward they would have to
co-group through the
rigmarole of planning yet again to get
that resolved and that is all the advice
i can give you because it's a
highly unusually written condition but
that issue essentially is not
the reserve matters in front of you
because of that mr depression
yes i yes i agree if if it is physically
impossible practically impossible to
comply with the condition then
in order to proceed with the development
they'd have to be a section 73
application to vary the condition
yes one more question about pedestrian
friendly you mentioned this
development's pedestrian friendly
i've been asking for clarification about
where this meets
the so-called footpath network because
where it's shown it contacts the the
footpath network
it's basically an area of broken paving
in front of some 60s built
housing so
that's why i want to see the picture and
see what the legality of that was thank
you i i have messaged
uh forgive me for doing this but aware
that you might need this
i have messaged my colleague and just
asked him if they could quickly look at
and i appreciate this is google street
view and i apologize
on behalf of officers not to have a
specific photo but this may help i'm
hoping this helps
that so that's not it that's
in front of that black car there
right uh can we possibly just go back to
the
map and then dive in again so we can
just orientate where we are
or is it just on the right hand side
yeah can you go forward and turn right
okay um
okay so if you go to that junction cut
the corner okay
so yeah go up there i apologize for this
right to the right that's the bit we're
looking at just turn the angle of the
camera to the right a bit
that's it that's so where your cursor
just was at where that bush was
i think is roughly where the connection
point would be
if that's okay council if you're okay to
take it from there
i think we've got a picture
next cancer melon so please
chairs a question for the developer is
that okay um
the question is about the uh are you
prepared to commit to a whole route
coming in from the north
to this site
um the whole route for your construction
traffic
uh are you prepared to commit to coming
in from the north i.e down clay lane in
turkey hall lane i'll bring this pokemon
before we go there
so condition 13 of the outline planning
permission
is for the construction management plan
and i'm just
going over that very quickly it should
say here yes it does means of access
traffic routes regular parking
maneuvering areas shall be agreed
so that is in place as a condition to be
agreed i
don't i'm not aware that's been agreed
yet though has it alex
no so that is still for agreement and
it's been conditioned accordingly
thank you any other questions please
okay in that case uh we're going to move
to debate so who'd like to start
oh sorry sorry we've got the award
member of canada oh and my apologies
yeah world member counselor mellon he
won't be voting on this
as he's the ward member as well carson
mellon my appendages
no fine thank you chair um no i don't
have a great deal to say
um just to give a little bit of
background
the outline application for this site
came forward at a time when mid-south
didn't have a five-year land supply the
site is outside the settlement boundary
um we probably wouldn't put this site
forward now but we are where we are it
has outlined permission i accept that
the construction will
will go ahead and my concern is is the
the poor design
of of this uh this development
and there's a couple of things um i've
already raised the issue of public
surveillance of the the main
area of open space i don't think that's
adequate it could have been designed
better
there's also a large area of parking a
sort of parking court
on the south of the site and that's
adjacent to
residential gardens of existing
dwellings off north close
and i think that is that is poor design
it's
it's putting parking right next to
existing gardens and there will be a lot
of immunity to those people
and that could have been designed better
as well
um the landscaping on the north boundary
of the development
again is poor and uh instead of
um there being uh a sort of screening
and
and softening of that boundary there
will be hard lines
landscaping in view from turkey hall
lane
um but the main concern about this site
is is the access
um turkey hill lane is a very narrow
lane and and it then joins onto clay
lane
which is basically a single track going
round
um and eventually joining up with the
b113
[Music]
the developer has to widen
turkey hall lane down to their site
um to make it a two-way
road it's not it's only a single track
with passing places at the moment
and that is absolutely necessary for
this this development to go ahead
myself and councillor string have
measured it on the ground we do not
believe
that 5.5 meters is achievable
with the existing highway taking a meter
either side as highways can
it goes beyond that in places so
i look forward to that being proved
wrong that they're able to do it but i
don't think they can at the moment
so we're left with a situation where
construction traffic
according to the developer once they've
done that work
we'll access the site off
turkey hall lane i.e coming through the
center of backton
i.e coming through hawley and hawley
green
and with the other sites in backton we
know this is going to
prove a real problem it's going to be
unacceptable to the community
because we already have a pinch point
and the pinch point is the primary
school
and if you try and get through back to
at the beginning or end of the school
day
it's almost impossible to to get through
with a car let alone
a lorry now it could be that the the
developers will
agree to a condition which limited
uh the lorries you know those times that
we should be great but i think
better would be if the whole route could
be from the north
and they could control the flow up and
down turkey hall and clay lane
um there's already provision i think in
in what they've suggested for for um
timings of of deliveries and so forth to
be
to be uh scheduled it should be possible
to bring in traffic from the north
um from the b113 turning right
into clay lane not left that would be
very dangerous
and i would like that to see that
condition put on
as part of the uh the things we've
discussed just a moment ago
but i'd really prefer that we deferred
this application to improve the design
that's what i'd like the committee to do
i realize that development will come
forward here but i think this is poor
and we could do better so that's um
really what i want to say thank you chad
thank you any questions for the ward
member
okay in that case we will move to debate
um who's going to start
everyone's been reluctant so i'll jump
in for them um
need to mention i'm the county
councillor for this area and i just want
to
give a tiny lecture to this district
council about not allowing
county councillors to speak at outline
applications
we really need to rethink this and this
particular item
is a particular case in point the the
conditions put on by the county council
original stage
are way way too weak and i'll go and
explain why
bacton is quite a unique village in
terms of its traffic generation
there's an awful lot of businesses which
is great brilliant it's an economic
little engine
it also has a very very low railway
bridge on the london to norwich railway
line
and we get repeated bridge strikes
either
on pound hill or junction of clay lane
and b1113
if a lorry strikes a bridge the london
norwich line has to be
closed until engineers have come out and
ruled that the bridges are still safe
that normally takes a minimum of two to
three hours
at 34 000 pounds an hour to the lorry
driver that hit it
which is why it's so imperative that
getting
hgvs into this site or any site in
backton
has to be done correctly if if a driver
makes a wrong turn
and tries to get under the large bridge
bang
it's shut then for a minimum of two
hours
the disruption widely is dreadful also
the cost
to the hauler and developer is going to
be significant
equally if you're coming in along the
designated lorry route which is the
b1113
and you try and turn left into clay lane
that is such a tight turn left you will
also strike the bridge
which happens quite regularly again
railway line has to be closed for an
engineer to rule
that there's nothing going to fall on
the railway line
turkey hall lane and clay lane
is a lorry route for anything trying to
avoid the low bridge
so what we've done here we've approved a
development on a very narrow
lane with no footpath provision in it
that is a lorry route
you understand why the the reserve
matters here are so utterly critical
and i have to say i hollowly laugh when
the county council then says by the way
can we have a footpath link leading you
north
there's no footpath to go to you're
going to be dicing
with an untreated yeah and
modified road with lorries that can't go
in two ways but they're expected to
so this is this is quite tight and that
routine needs to be
absolutely pivotal and central to the
building out of this
okay that's the highways bit over with
uh
equally coupled with the fact i was at
councilman said there's probably nearly
400 homes going to be built
in the next few years in backton and
this is the first one of them i believe
at reserve matter stage so it's
important we get the routine correct
getting onto this plan i have to say
when i saw
the second iteration of this plan i was
i was probably mortified
in terms of we had a design originally
outlined stage which was
could have probably rubbed along with
this one i have significant issues with
i'm very surprised the police haven't
responded to the
unsurveyed area of playing area where
there is
just the other side of the hedge there
has been regular police activity
because of the other side of the hedges
in the current playing field
where we do have issues with that being
so far away from where people can see
so having a new designed play area here
where basically you've got nobody
overlooking it at all
is is is reckless i feel
and also is not recommended in the in
designing out crime
and the secure by design it goes against
that
whereas the the front entrance has been
recognized that we have got people that
cross overlook it so that can be
secured i think my greatest
regret about this is how this completely
ruins the residential immunity of of the
people in that last little row
the person that lived in that end house
which has been extended
so actually is a lot closer to this new
development as proposed in this plan
has had 30 40 years of uninterrupted
views of countries like the basic
field to the right of them okay that's
changed so what they would have had
effect in their residential meaning
is a couple of tractors a year and
probably a combine harvester
they've now got a built form which i
believe is a block of flats right near
them
and also to add to that in your back
garden you've now got a car park
brilliant i think that's an appalling
design
in the 21st century particularly in what
is a
rural location this is a rural location
so for me this current design i wouldn't
i wouldn't defer it i'd blatantly refuse
it because i think it is that poor
thank you chair thank you councillor
stringer anybody else
we all must have some thoughts on this
so let's let's voice them
could i just very briefly explore the
surveillance
point made and alex is it possible to
get the plan back on
screen for me
just so i can understand the point being
made if i can sorry yeah
john yes the the the area of
resident of amenity land at the at the
front of open space at the front
yeah that is overlooked by that row of
houses
and the houses can look across the road
and they it
surveyed from almost an ark yeah so they
think that the fun of those houses
overlook and and the front particularly
of the existing houses
is very close so that so the
surveillance from there
is is quite heavy-duty so we go to the
other area which is the
square space to the right-hand side
there's nothing there we've got one two
three four houses on that boundary whose
rear garden are they bungalows or are
they two-story at that point
alex if you can tell me
the two stories so we've got first floor
bedroom windows overlooking
yeah um and then we've got another
property to the left which is
also got its rear garden so i'll stop
that debate point actually i think it's
tenuous
i think i just wanted to make sure we're
clear of what yeah
houses are it's almost been deliberately
designed so nobody's overlooking it
without a living area
that's strictly not true because we've
just seen the map and we can see
actually as mr payment jews point out
there's lee spoorhouse looking out so i
do get your point
from a sorry chair from a bedroom yeah
so what
yeah from a bedroom yeah the the the
overlooking
insecure by design is from living areas
i'm sorry uh if i may just sorry if i
may just come in um
ultimately i wasn't looking to have an
argument over the actual
what he's overlooking or not i just
wanted to assess the nature of the
overlooking and i just wanted to clarify
that that's what we're talking about
here thank you
in the secure by design it says the
overlook should be from living areas
like kitchens and living rooms that kind
of area that are populated for the
majority of the time
i think get your point thank you anybody
else wish to enter debate
from my point of view then if nobody
council do you want to come in
[Music]
yes i'm just trying to sort of put some
ideas together i thought
look the parish council is concerned
about the loss of open space
and i i've thought about this
you know you're losing from the
from the initial proposition
you had you had an open space the size
of a crooked field
and i taken both the parish council's
concern that
uh they may lose which i think is
a sad idea the the um was it queen mary
playing field um
adjacent to the railway line um
and that's going to be replaced by
something which is half the size of a
cricket cricket field i didn't think the
the though that perhaps the setting of
um
the heritage asset might be improved by
the
more open space along the side of the
road
but the access is is really worrying i
have
i have driven down that road it is very
narrow i can't
i wouldn't like to really meet a lorry
coming the other way
um there's very little scope for
maneuver
but i think one of my concerns mostly is
about the grouping together
of the affordable housing i realize that
there are
that this is uh on the um
advice of the agent that's going to to
manage these properties
but um from a social point of view it
it isn't recommended so
i don't think there are really
enough positives about the new proposal
of design really to help
help me make a decision in favor
it hasn't moved it hasn't moved forward
i don't think i think if anything
especially from the parish council's
point of view it's a retrogressive
move thank you anybody else
can you put the um map up please that
shows the
previous proposal on the current
proposal
and while we're doing that mr pinky um i
should obviously point out that
ultimately the outline uh plan we're
referring to was indicative
um and you know we we would expect
something maybe similar but there are
also alternative ideas that could have
come forward
it was a matter stage your judgment here
is whether the alternative
proposal in front of you is suitable in
terms of layout design
appearance and and so forth in terms of
the reserve matters before you
i will say this though just to add um
the the proposal outline
uh secured open space to be provided
it did not secure the level of open
space to be provided
that was not dealt with on at that time
and therefore
we've got nothing specific to say there
should be a minimum of x
for the open space area just to bear
that in mind should we get into the
conversation about
minimal spaces thank you it's useful
um so put both maps up there just so we
can refresh ourselves on what was before
us before
and what is now and um in terms of the
open space in my opinion it's only my
opinion
um actually it looks a little bit more
open that's the first thing straight
away just looking at that
yeah there's a great big area to the
northeast but look we still got an area
to northeast we've got one to the west
we've got one to the north and actually
uh council warboy is what you said was
right
gives more protection really to that
listed building outlook as well so it's
a good
thing and when it comes down to the
buildings in the south in my opinion
it's less of an issue on amenity for the
houses that are currently there
because there's less of them now when it
comes to car parking the open spaces for
cars
i don't honestly see how that affects
immunity and i looked at immunity
it talks about privacy it talks about
overbearing effects
talks about natural light and outlook
environmental effects and other design
guidance
i don't see actually there's a major
issue
or an immunity loss to the houses that
currently reside on the selfless estate
that's just my opinion based on what
i've just read and it's up to you to
decide whether it is or
whether it isn't i guess all of us in
fact
the surveillance side of it for the
protection of the plane areas
is arguable and i think your point's
well made actually um
but i don't think it's a stopper to be
honest with you now the road layout
or the housing layout in my opinion is
better than what was before us before
but my major concern is the
transportation hdbs et cetera coming
down to turkey lane
and obviously the aspects council
stringer brought out about the bridge in
bapton
to me that is still a bit of an issue i
don't
think and correct me if i'm wrong
there's enough condition in there
to assure it and i need to be assured
that that works going to be good
and that work is feasible before i could
go with this
so mr play machine come back on that one
um i can't give you that assurance
because
the way the condition is worded puts it
in the hands of suffolk county council
highways
so only they can give you the assurance
as the highways authority
and i would expect them to be mindful in
their
considerations of highway safety as they
should be that is their job
which is pretty much the conclusion most
of us probably came to
um there is condition there so we either
trust
in that highways we have a trust in
suffolk county council to abide
and the agents to abiding that condition
or not because that's what we're talking
about
if that's the one stop gap we're talking
about trust element and
the legal side of it so it's up to us to
decide
council having them thanks
um i don't think i'm really going to
help much because um i prefer the old
design
i don't like um i don't like the
affordable housing or being grouped
together i don't like that um that
cluster i think that's too many houses
in one corner i think they look crowded
there
and so i do prefer the original design
but whether we can turn this down
poor design and hang all you know
everything on that is another thing i
don't like the idea of the um
the hdb is going down that road or
hitting that bridge but um
if this is um already got through it
outline on i don't know if that like i
said apart from what
the condition is already there whether
we can do anything about that but um
unless someone is prepared to um propose
that we turn it down
to poor design which i'm not prepared to
do that
i think very sort of about an impasse
really counselling thank you and um
obviously just going back to the
description of development and partly
with the
reserve matters part of it is layout um
so that's got
a point um so you need to think about if
you're going to go refuse you need to
think about what you're going to refuse
it on
as far as the social housing goes and
the
um pepper pop
potting idea i've had them all over the
place um as
as it's stated these houses look no
different than normal houses
um so what are we saying that we just
don't like all people in social housing
living in the same area
i mean what's that about the dynamics
and the economics about it makes sense
to me
and if the houses look the same they're
normal people what's the problem
i don't get it but that's my opinion
based on northern housing estates they
used to live in that is my opinion
so at the end of the day i don't think
that's a factor
i think is wrong with us to actually say
that
it shouldn't be the way it is personally
but that's just my opinion so the stern
debate
anybody else
coaster
[Music]
yeah i'm of the opinion that the second
design is the better design
i know i'm that's there's a lot of um
disagreement in this
chamber but um the um
the affordable housing yeah i don't
agree
in separating the affordable housing
from the rest of it i think it's um
it's got nothing to do with anything
apart from you um
you so you have an area that's
affordable it's all affordable
and i think it should be mixed them up
amongst the um
the other houses so everything's exactly
the same there's no one
there's no different groupings but um
i think um every with this um
this new design everybody gets a bit of
that
open space and it's it's um
in that in environment you've got the um
you've got the driving in as well
through the open space i think that's
quite important as well
and rather than having it tucked in at
the back and um
it's quite a um it's quite a large
amount of open space
in one place um so
i yeah i i can understand what
counselors are saying
about having a reasonably tall building
backing on to
another dwelling and existing dwelling
but i think that's better than the um
original
because of the orientation of it and um
yeah i i think well yeah we've got to
hope that suffolk county council are
completely on top of other issues in
here
but from this meeting from what we're
doing here i think that um i would go
for approval of this
application
to take that as a proposal
yes happy to propose okay so we have a
proposal for approval do we have a
second day
okay council stringer i'd like to put a
counter proposal check
i i put a counter proposal and this is
me stepping down somewhat that we defer
this
for reconsideration because i believe it
is contrary to policy gp1
in the joint local plan it clearly says
the interrelationship between buildings
and open spaces in any layout
should act to minimize opportunities for
criminal behavior consistently good
layer and architectural design
i don't believe this does that it also
suggests
that the design should enhance
enhance for all concerned i cannot
believe
that that person living in that house at
the end of north close they're going to
be enhanced
the issue about the car park it's not so
much about the car itself
it's the nature of the people entering
and exiting the car
at whatever time of day or night the
banging of car doors
cars nowadays have all sorts of bleepers
on them that open up the back
yeah that is going to ruin their
residential amenity
frankly and that could have easily been
designed out
even after a bit of consultation thank
you so i would
move that we defer this application with
the agents everyone hearing
our concerns for them to try and
redesign this thank you
thank you so we didn't have a second we
do have a second uh proposal before i go
any further we need a second into that
proposal please
council gold
thank you chair yeah i i would um i
would second uh
catch the stringer's proposal um i
i don't ever believe that a decision
should be deferred simply because it's
difficult
think there are enough issues here
uh that if they're subject to the
officer's advice
that if we have scope to
allow further consideration of the
of the design i don't know i was
thinking what a shame that we can't
condition the county council's
conditioning
um i'm thinking i'm right i'm saying
that's not legally
permissible but
if a deferral allows time
to
establish the county council's approach
on the matter then i think that would
that would be beneficial
um but i i think in these circumstances
deferral
does seem a wise course of action
council will voice yes i i think i'll
support
deferral um
as well but is it possible to defer
also to get some designed proposal from
suffolk
county councils the high how the uh
the roadway no no no
you could we can't have that as for that
no but i'll get your support
this is pokemon g um essentially we
already have that we have a drawing
that's been secured by the
uh outline although i admit we haven't
got that to present so
obviously if we did come back we have
that drawing to hand if that was do we
not yeah we should have that
on the outline application um but i
can't help you with that particular
request
um was so i missed two seconds it was
there a second
or we haven't got a second again yeah
the second is uh councillor gold thank
you
so anybody else wish to enter the debate
we do have a proposal in the secondary
i just like to summarize it it's nice to
put some weight to the argument on the
security and actually now we've got
something
tangible that came right into the into
the proposal so thank you for that work
therefore we do have a proposal and the
second last the governance officer
please to
read the proposal and go to the
electronic vote
thank you chair could i just clarify
with mr payment what specifically
because i haven't
got down what parts of the actual
deferral is on so if i could just
clarify
i thought we were still having that
debate if i'm honest with you um so far
from councillor stringer
i have got that the proposal represents
poor design and layout um picking up
specifically
on the parking of cars adjacent to
residents of north
close in the rear car park i was unclear
though
and then obviously there's associated
harm to amenity with that
if the surveillance of open space
areas and placement of affordable
housing were part of that concern
certainly for me the the the over
the surveillance of the is the
affordable housing less so
you can already identify affordable
housing on an estate and
the ones without the garage it's quite
simple so
i'm less worried about that i'm more
worried about
future crime and criminal activity and
whatever going on
by policy uh when we have clear ones
that are supposed to
prevent this secondary contemporary
thank you so it's not the affordable
housing fine that's fine so we've got
those two elements
um i was going to suggest that h16 might
come into it as well as gp1 but i will
leave that there thank you
bear with me two seconds chair i'll just
write part of that up
so
sorry thank you chad so just to confirm
the vote that will be before members is
the application dc 21
000 641 be deferred for the reasons as
read out by the area planning manager
just now
is everyone clear what they are
okay did you want me to read them out
one more time
i think that would be prudent okay so
i've got down here the first development
i'm sorry
the development currently represents
poor design and layout
including lacquer suitable surveillance
of open space areas
parking your cars immediately adjacent
to residential gardens
and therefore fails the provisions of
gp1
thank you thank you chair i've now
opened the vote so if members could
please go to the plus sign in the top
right hand corner of today's agenda
and go on the subsection of attendance
voting and then please click on the blue
line
which shows the vote in progress
counselor casting can i please take your
vote
verbally you i'll vote for deferral
thank you councilman
thank you chair all votes have now been
received with councilman not voting as
the board member
as per the planning charter and that
means the vote is carried unanimously
by seven votes thank you that is carried
um as we said before has previously
noted the applications that were due for
this afternoon which was zero one seven
four
seven and zero one eight zero zero have
been withdrawn by the applicants and
will not be heard this afternoon
um site inspections none declared thank
you
in that case thank you for all your
efforts and contributions
and good to see you all stay safe and i
end the meeting